Hello Freak pitches this episode,
the Joe Rogan experience podcast is brought to you by stamps.com if you go to
stamps.com you can sell all sorts of shit online and measure it and weigh it off
from your house.
Like we were talking about the other day.
If you have an exotic thing that you make from your own home and you want to
sell it yourself,
you don't want to go to the post office and say,
Hey,
can you,
can you weigh out these whale bone dildos?
You don't have to do that.
You could do it all yourself and they'll provide you with a,
an actual postage scale so you can weigh everything out and they'll also provide
you with $55 of a free postage.
If you use the code word j r e x a Joe,
it's $110 bonus offer.
Yeah,
it's what?
Nevermind.
You're professionals.
Fuck yeah,
they give me all that stuff for free.
Sign Up,
use the Cobra Jerry and you can send shit online.
Like Brian Sends those,
those desk squad dot t v t shirts.
All those get sent directly through stamps.com super easy to do.
Measure it all from your computer or print it all out in your home printer and
then the postman comes and takes it away.
He got out all that nonsense of going to the actual fucking post office and
waiting in line and then someone looking at you that does not want to see you
with a stupid box of shit that you have to weigh out and then send off to
people.
This is way easier.
And uh,
if you have a home business and,
um,
why wouldn't you,
that's probably a good thing to do in this day and age.
Figuring out a home business.
Get on stamps.com.
Use The code word j Ari and save yourself some money.
What also brought to you by [inaudible] dot com that's o n n I t a human
optimization website.
Kathleen Madigan.
Do you ever take brain pills?
You no fuck around with that shit.
It don't do they work well?
It do make us smarter.
Fuck No.
Make it lift more.
Poo.
Pooed is a Russian and unit of weight.
Um,
uh,
they,
they basically enhance your brain's ability to produce neurotransmitters.
So all the,
uh,
the nutrients and building blocks for the key components of,
of thinking,
they've kind of broken down certain nutrients that can enhance mental clarity.
Some that actually boosts serotonin.
We sell this stuff called new mood in new mood is how five HTP and l tryptofan
supplement.
That's my favorite one.
It's great stuff.
And it,
what it does is it literally enhances your brain to produce happy chemicals.
Yeah.
Well I'm pretty happy person anyway,
but yes,
it definitely has an effect.
It's a legit scientific effect and the,
the combining of El Tryptophan and five HTP l Tryptofan converts in the body to
five HTP.
So it's sort of like a time released benefit of having the two of them mixed in
together.
Um,
these are one of those things though that you,
if you're on an Ssri,
you shouldn't take it.
So if you're on an antidepressant,
you shouldn't take it because a,
they both enhance,
um,
the,
your,
your levels of certain chemicals like dopamine.
So I don't,
I don't think you're supposed to take the two of them together.
So be careful of that because I know that,
um,
like our friend Neil Brennan,
he's,
he actually stopped taking five HTP because his doctor was telling him he's
taking like both an Ssri and five HTP.
You can overload.
Your brain is not,
it's not a happiness chemicals.
There's a balance man.
And when the balance goes to the wrong way,
it's not good with anything,
you know,
whether it's adrenaline or whatever it is that when the balance is off,
whacked out,
it's not good.
When's this essentially what happens to people when they get depressed?
For a lot of them,
at least chemicals in the first place is that the brain is not balanced
properly.
They're chemicals on a balanced.
So if you're thinking about taking anything like that new mood or even even
Alpha brain,
I would talk to a doctor,
but the doctor's is probably going to tell you.
And vitamins are all bullshit,
right?
Doctors,
you know what?
It's so shocking when you find out how little time in medical school doctors
actually have to devote to nutrition.
It's like,
it's nothing.
It's like a regular person,
you know,
reading a book.
It's really not that big a deal unless you specialized in nutrition or
biochemistry or absorption of vitamins.
And most doctors don't really the wells,
you know,
multivitamins not even necessarily eat healthy.
Well fuck eats healthy enough to not take a bite of it.
And that's what I want to know.
Who are you that eats so healthy?
You don't need multivitamins.
Shut the fuck up bitch.
Unless you're eating salads every goddamn meal and a big one at that and then
you're eating like really clean food,
you probably need to,
vitamins don't get sick.
You know,
it's even crazier.
It's nowadays that people that buy reports from other people that companies
like,
uh,
like if you need a report on your thyroid and your,
you're going to school to become a doctor,
you pay $10 per page for this other guy to write the whole thing for you.
I met a guy who does it.
What are you saying?
Right.
The whole Wa like report.
Like if that homework,
so these doctors that are going to college and stuff that have to write all
these exams and reports and stuff like that,
they just pay people to pay people the right $10 a page.
That makes sense.
You're so swamped with work.
Yeah.
When you're going through your residency.
I have had two friends,
two close friends that went through their residency,
one for ophthalmology and I forgot what my other friend was going on,
what,
what particular field of medicine,
but the amount of time that these guys have to spend studying is insane.
My friend junks sick went through medical school and then into residency and I
watched the whole thing and it was,
it's not even humanly possible.
You're just basically stretching the body out to the point where just before it
snaps and then you red line it like that.
Every day these fucking people are working 16 hour days.
My friend Steve fell asleep on the toilet eating lunch and his pager went off in
that woke them up.
That's how tired he was and that's how little time he had.
He would regularly sleep an a night and then they're in the hospital in the
emergency room.
Man.
I mean,
people were coming in with,
people came in with gunshot wounds.
One guy had a light bulb stuffed up his ass.
I mean,
you're dealing with real shit and you have one hour sleep like four or five days
in a row.
You got to help the gunshot guy.
First Light Bulb,
man,
you made some choices.
Gunshots.
Probably safer wound is if it's a,
if it's somewhere in your calf or something,
Ass ass light bulb was one of the worst ones I've ever heard.
Anybody who's ever done a residency in an emergency room and tell you some cuff
fucking raising stories almost every day to yeah,
yeah,
it can happen.
Um,
so don't do that.
Instead,
go take some Alpha brain,
good for your brain.
Uh,
and we have the prime new primal kettle bells in as well.
Then the kettlebells with the,
um,
the ape designs in them,
and if you buy the orangutan,
we donate $5 the orangutans and new one.
It's a 54 pounds.
We donate $5 from every sale of the rank time,
one to a a.
Um,
it's a collective or something that helps save orangutans.
I don't really remember the exact name of it,
but I know it's all up on a on.com has o n n I t use the code named Rogan and
save 10% off any and all supplements.
I take them all,
it's all shit that I would use in real life and do yours.
So,
uh,
I stand behind it and you know what I stand behind Brian.
Oh than that.
Hmm.
You Q and a music bitch.
Kathleen Madigan is here.
I respect.
Okay.
Right now,
hold on.
They get new iPad.
Joe Rogan planned obsolescence.
Try by day.
Joe Rogan podcast by night all day.
Brian is
king of the grand conspirators when it comes to planned obsolescence for
laptops.
Every time like a new operating system comes out,
they make your phone slow down.
You have to get a new phone.
You're the king of that.
Right?
You can really believe that they actually engineer that.
Oh,
that's absent.
I think it's even been proven.
I mean it hasn't been.
Can you have to also think that a lot of times when they make a phone it's four
one single,
the software's designed around one single graphic processor,
one single processor and blah blah blah.
So that every time they make a new one they have a different processor and they
kind of backs,
you know,
engineer it to make it work a little bit with this.
But yeah,
it's all,
it's all reverse engineer.
Well that's always been the argument about apple.
Why apple is so good is because they make the hardware and they make the
software that makes it,
two of them go together perfectly.
You don't have to worry about like the million different android type phones
that are made from Samsung and this guy and that guy.
And I'm remember Motorola and it's not always,
it didn't always work perfectly because of that.
Same as like windows.
Computers got a bunch of different shit you got shoved in there.
It doesn't always work perfectly.
Speaking of foot,
I just found one of the greatest new tips that will help most iPhone users,
specially females.
And it's when you plug it in and you're looking at your storage and your,
it says like you music,
uh,
whatever.
And then it has other and the others like a super big and we're like,
what's this other?
And it doesn't tell you what that means.
I found out that that is people's text messages,
like all the photos and videos.
Like if you don't delete your text messages and you have,
or you have that one where it's like you and one person had been talking for the
last year and a half but you've just never deleted it and started over.
That's just a saving all those old videos and photos that you've sent me.
Data.
Yeah.
So mine,
I just noticed that the other day was uh,
I think it was like 30 gigs of just other,
and I'm like,
what the fuck is this other?
And I just started deleting and just dump the whole thing.
Yeah,
you can't,
well you just have to go through each thread and just like swipe it to the
right.
Delete.
It's like you can just clear all maybe
let's see.
Edit.
Oh yeah.
You could just go down the list and hit the red dots.
Are those dots are all automatically?
No,
I mean like I could go through here and just like,
uh,
I don't know.
Oh,
like you want to keep one?
Yeah.
Right,
right,
right.
Powerful.
Kathleen Madigan,
how do you do powerful,
but I just got a little lost in the beginning there.
Are you saying if you get a new computer or your phone slows down?
Well,
no,
no.
He's saying when the new operating systems come out in the new computers come
out,
they,
they purposely engineer the new operating system to fuck with the older
computers to make it slower.
Meaning like,
like today apple just released a new software update for their iPhone.
So you plug it into your computer,
you can update it to a brand new.
Uh,
it looks like all brand new operating says everything looks different now on
your iPhone.
And people are already saying that it's just slowing their shit down and stuff
like that because that means they want you to go,
oh yeah,
my shit sucks now so I might by this new iPhone that's been programmed for this
operating.
So it makes sense.
Here's why it makes sense.
Sounds.
But it's also a double edged sword,
isn't it?
I mean I'm not afraid,
I'm not a technology person,
but I would think that when you're using new hardware and new advanced stuff,
you kind of have to engineer stuff for that new advanced hardware if you're
going to get the full benefits out of it.
Right.
Here's the new operating system that it looks like the old shit,
everything's bigger,
they can't see it.
So what's going on Kathleen Madigan now that you've heard phone one oh one I
know it's a lot to,
you boys have a lot going on here with technology.
I have a giant Samsung that's basically,
those are dope.
That's the galaxy s four it's really pretty huge.
They're the best for like going online reading shit.
Like you don't actually read it.
It's huge.
It's our little law.
The note is the nuttiest one.
You've seen that one scene to know.
You know what's weird too is all the guys at the sprint store,
that young guys,
they have it of course,
but they're also gigantic.
That in their pocket is like this in my pocket.
But that's pretty big in your pocket too.
That's the thing about the iPhone without a case is absolutely perfect.
That should just slides in your pocket.
So perfect size.
Well the young people seem to like the note.
You know the young people love the big,
the big screen and now it does four k video.
It does this insanely high definition video
right off the camera.
It does shed that.
I found campus wouldn't think guys would want something that big in their pocket
trying to be sexy.
But guys,
we're just trying to,
I guess some room to fill.
We also get really,
uh,
guys get addicted to like gadgets that can do more.
It's a very strange thing.
We don't know why it is better than yours.
Check what I can do and you can't do it.
There's definitely that,
but we always are thirsty for the new shit that will never even use,
like to just got an infrared on it.
You can change the channel.
You could change the channel with these things now.
So now,
oh,
get ready for this folks.
Every asshole at a bar,
it was going to think he's cute.
He's going to be changing the fucking channels on the TV over and over again.
You know football is going to be on and he's going to think it's cute to put on
Romper room cause that Shit's gonna happen.
It's gonna happen.
People are going to use like,
I am not interested.
I don't know anything this on does.
And not even the guy said,
no,
do you want me to give you a little lesson?
And I was like,
ah,
no.
I don't think Miguel,
who is 23 he liked me as a comedian.
You know me as a comedian,
but I don't think,
yeah,
you never know.
I called Miguel called me and it rang.
I go,
I'm good.
That's all I need to know.
It works.
It's a phone I could text.
Yeah.
Apparently it has super powers.
I'm not aware of it.
Do you ever use like apps,
like applications for stuff?
ESPN,
that's about it.
Oh,
you're a sports fan.
Felt well,
sadly I'm a rams fan.
I have no idea what that means.
It's a,
it's a bad pro hockey,
football,
football.
They're not doing well.
Terrible.
Oh,
I watch football and the cardinals.
St Louis Cardinals.
Good.
I watch baseball and uh,
I don't know if I have any other apps.
Oh,
around me.
Doesn't like comedy.
Central's comes central.
Have an APP.
Probably everyone should.
You do what?
You can do it around me.
Wait,
is that one of the dating ones are just no rounds for like restaurants thing.
When you're on the road,
let's say you're in some town,
you know nothing about town.
Instead of actually having to speak to people.
If I'm in York,
Pennsylvania and I hit Irish pub and you shake it like a magic eight ball and
see how I do this,
you shake it.
What's up?
Sometimes it says you have to do it in a figure eight.
Oh,
that's what the GPS will work somehow or another.
As crazy as I call it,
a phone would say that move your hand in the shape of a figure eight.
I'm like,
I'm just totally being punked by these people.
There's just some kid who put that in there so that people are walking around go
like this all day,
but I did it and it worked.
I'm like,
wow.
It really was still around me.
It's the greatest app for the road.
You can find anything,
anything.
It's pretty good.
It's pretty good like that to y'all.
It was nice too because you get to see the reviews.
I know,
but people get too wordy and then,
I don't know.
I don't trust the reviews because one bad experience or maybe somebody just got
to pull up their ass about a lot of people.
A lot of pull up their ass people.
Yup.
Is the camp that is like the Kingdom of the,
they live.
They live on Yelp and your shit on businesses.
How you go do that?
You know,
I'm a Yelp gold member.
I,
I've got over 70,000 reviews.
That's a,
I don't think I have really any other apps that I use.
weather.com I'm that.
I'm just that Kiki.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that's it.
Huh?
That's fine.
It's enough.
You use the web browser.
Do you get online with that thing?
It's a big giant ass screen.
Yup.
I can read anything.
Perfect.
Get your email and I have a mini iPad and they're like little tiny computers
now.
Yes.
It's going to be weird when they become a part of our bodies,
that Shit's going to happen.
It's going to happen nice and slow.
This is us already in your email.
It's going to be in,
you're going to see any of that
right?
Walls or something?
Yeah.
I think it'll be on your wrist.
Like,
uh,
like when you're born they'll just put your little TV in.
I think they're gonna be able to see it in your eyeballs.
I think they're going to have my goal.
That's what they're working on.
Like a contact lens.
How are you going to turn that off?
Uh,
I guess I'll have to take it out.
You don't have to take the lens out.
Oh,
you put the Lens,
what I already have context.
So I put it the lens over my lines.
Be a contact lens with some sort of Nano devices in it that will illuminate
things in front of your eyes and give you directions and show it to you.
Like it's a screen,
like a giant screen in front of you.
I am already predicting so many.
Okay.
I can't see close up or far,
far away.
Like I just can't see it.
All right.
So if there's something this close that I'm supposed to read,
I'd have to put my glasses on.
Well,
there'll be the lead the lens that wouldn't work.
No,
I don't think this can work for people with bad vision.
I bet.
I bet it Ken.
I bet they just adjust it to whatever your vision is,
how bad they just make it so that you know,
like a contact lens on.
Yeah.
If it's a contact lens,
this is obviously me with zero science and no technical knowledge of we're
finding this is possible.
But I would imagine that you would be able to accurately,
uh,
imitate the same effect that you get them on a three dimensional movie screen,
which is flat as well.
I quite,
well why can't you do that in with,
uh,
with,
with the text and the images that you show?
And if that's the case,
why can't you tune it?
Like lasses why can't you tune it to where a person's vision would and wouldn't
work?
It's a Lens,
you know,
I mean,
it's just like a contact lens.
So you're saying you'd have to be fitted for your vision and then they would
just put the thing on that,
right?
Until they came up to you one day.
And then when Kathleen Madigan,
why keep fucking around with these?
Realize we've got artificial eyes that works so much better.
So let's let late,
let's scoop your eyeballs out and slamming these bad boys and they're awesome.
You'll be able to fucking see through walls and people think you're dope.
Yeah.
Well,
I would do that.
I'm already planning on,
uh,
Mark Ridley,
the guy who owns the club in Detroit and he's owned it forever.
His mom is 80 and had ocular implants and now she's a driver for all of our old
people friends.
Cause now she has 20,
20 vision.
What is an ocular implant?
I really know except that they put new isen you'd have to Google it.
I don't know.
Google.
It's a surgery though for old people.
Two weeks.
That's all.
You're out of the game and then you're back in the game and she has perfect
vision.
It's crazy.
Brian said just googling silly pictures.
Why don't you look up ocular implants?
That's a,
that's what that robot,
I,
that's not real though.
That's just some goofy picture.
Ocular implants and popular science.
Yeah.
Electrodes.
Jesus Christ.
Future is here.
Electrodes in print and Clinton implanted in the retina.
Blind patients can read.
Wow.
Yeah.
That's insane.
That is insane.
What are you looking at?
And then there's another one.
There's another one that's working on a completely different,
um,
in a,
in a completely different area there,
but they have a different retinal implant that can lead blind people to,
to see and it's fractal shaped eye implants and they mimic neurons allowing
blind people to see Jesus fucking Christ.
Who are these people?
It's working.
It's amazing.
There's an 80 year old lady driving around Detroit at nighttime.
Man,
this is insane stuff.
I,
yeah,
I've,
I find it incredibly fascinating and I don't,
this is just the beginning of all this stuff.
They,
they literally are going to have artificial bodies that work better than our
body.
They're just going to have to figure out a way to get your brain into it.
I saw that episode of your show where they're talking about it.
It's all a little,
at some point though,
do you really want to be immortal?
This sounds like the beginning of a superhero movie.
Why,
what do you know?
Do you really want to be a mortal?
Um,
that's a good question.
What happened?
Did I
the thing out?
Yeah.
You probably pop the court out.
Um,
that question,
do you really want to be a moral?
It's a good question because no,
what if life is what life is not as good as what's next.
You know what if we leave life and there literally is another dimension where
you're not contained by your ego and your body and your life experiences and
your past.
What if this just never ends?
I mean at some point sometimes I'm already bored.
Really.
I mean,
what are we going to do when we're 511 I mean,
seriously,
how many do we get to do tomorrow?
Isn't it the same thing?
No,
you don't look forward to tomorrow.
Yes,
but there's things tomorrow that I haven't done yet.
I think I'll be doing the same things over and over again.
Well then you would like it mortality,
Joe.
Just as you though,
not as something different.
Like you just get to live forever.
I
thank that life today is filled with so many fascinating things that you can do.
So many fascinating things.
You can learn so many fascinating things that you could experience and just read
about and watch documentaries on.
I never get bored.
I don't think you can get boards today fee for me,
I feel like if you're bored today,
it's because you're trying to be bored because if you
really pay attention,
there's so much cool and interesting shit out there and I see a lot going on.
I would just say fine enough tire.
It's wise.
I can't find enough time.
I can't find enough time to do the things I love.
I would like,
I would like a million more lives of these people who sleeps five hours.
I sleep when I have to sleep.
You know,
I sleep like I tried to sleep eight hours a day.
You shouldn't really fuck around with your body like that.
I think when I would be the first one to sign up for 10 hours,
I have not.
But the people that really love life seem to sleep a lot less than I do.
I don't know about that.
I just,
I think they're silly.
You,
you really should.
Sleeping is one of the most important things a person can do.
You can live your life on like four and five hours sleep at night,
but you're not optimum.
You're just not,
you're not going to be optimum.
You're not going to feel optimum.
You're not going to perform optimum.
It's the Bill Clintons.
I mean,
he did it.
That was his big thing.
Swarts and I here too.
He does it to really,
yeah.
Well he certainly does get a lot done in a day.
Good for you.
Aren't all of that.
Thank you.
I think that,
um,
it's,
it really important to get at least six.
I think when you get,
you know,
stress and exercise and whatever you're doing during the day,
your body needs to decompress and then it needs to recharge.
But there's also a joy and sleeping.
I don't know why people don't understand the pleasure of deep sleep.
Hmm.
The pleasure.
Certainly when you get up and you're like,
oh,
that was so good.
I slept so good.
I don't know
really smart people like Bill Clinton,
you know,
Rhodes scholar,
a guy,
and it's five hours and I think I'm just,
I'm not that motivated.
I think everybody's the same though.
You know,
I think some people,
five hours is good.
I think everybody's body is different.
Just I know for me I need eight hours.
If I don't get eight hours,
I feel stupid.
What did you have your brain pills that helps health?
These are really good.
If I,
if I'm jet lagged or if I'm traveling somewhere and I'm only getting a few hours
sleep,
I have to do something where I have to use my brain like a show sometimes that
difficult.
Yeah.
You're flying somewhere.
You leave early in the morning,
flying someone there and you go like right on stage.
Yeah.
But uh,
I'll balance it out before,
make sure the night before I got some sleep.
Shit's important.
Counseling Madigan,
my mortality I have,
he's not buying it.
I have to get eight or more.
I don't know how you guys do it.
Less than an eight.
Mm.
That's hard.
10 is what a hand is what I,
yeah,
that's a good number right there.
I love second in line.
Yeah.
Then yeah,
I just feel like better.
It's like everything got done in the night that needed to get done.
You know,
even problems,
even things that are bugging you,
it's amazing how you just sleep on them and you wake up in the lane.
The answer comes clear in the dream or,
yeah.
Well that's one of the reasons
is that they think you're taking a psychedelic trip when you're,
uh,
when you're dreaming dream chemicals,
like the chemicals associated with dreaming really very similar to chemicals
associated with a psychedelic plants.
I wonder,
uh,
if you use nicotine patches and you keep them on at your dreams,
go like into hyperdrive sanity talked about this before,
but I think,
yeah,
that's right.
I used to do it.
Yeah.
To dream more.
Well,
yeah.
Oh yeah.
It'll take you on a ride like no other.
I mean it,
but it's almost like if you're saying all those chemicals are there from a
dream,
the nicotine just fast forwards it faster and then adds more.
It keeps you in nicotine receptors,
uh,
awake.
So when it happens is,
is that you're dreaming while things are on that are supposed to be turned off.
It's fucked up.
Yeah.
But it's really everybody should put on a patch once and go to sleep.
Get the little,
actually they actually,
yeah,
I was going say did they actually say don't do it?
Cause it's like,
I guess there's probably something that's bad for you that you can like get
really seriously injured doing that.
Like oh wow.
Yeah.
Flailing around or something like that.
So I recommend just like,
like a half or a quarter even.
I don't recommend it at all.
But like if you're going to do it,
don't use a full pout.
Definitely don't use a for you.
Do you,
have you ever done a full patch?
All right.
Yeah,
but the,
I have had the patch on the whole day from having it on and I just fell asleep.
Delete.
Yes.
Well it's if you put them on late night shows to bedtime.
Yeah.
So I,
I had like,
this is a kind of dumb ass dream.
The nicotine,
there was like a rap competition and I was forced to enter,
but you had to stutter and I ended up winning the gold medal for my song.
I always remember a song at all.
Well,
I don't remember my song,
but my character was,
I was cheesy,
e e,
z and then the whole crowd would go easy,
but I'd make them,
I make a wait for it.
Then I'd change it up.
I go cheesy.
He,
they never knew when it was coming
in my dream I was with Louis Black and I made them go downtown to a,
I had to go pick up my gold medal.
It was a tough post office downtown La.
I was like,
I've never been to the post office,
but this is the nicotine.
Like he just,
how vivid was it?
Oh,
I can't even describe the metal.
And it came in like this crossed I box.
I'm like,
this is kind of religiously odd.
Why are they,
is the Olympics getting into religion?
And it also makes it makes your dreams like a,
like an action movie.
Like,
like,
like everything's really like,
well,
like the story's really good and
very clear.
All of the stuff.
Yeah.
In real life that I'm capable of injuries.
I don't mean physically,
I mean to think of those things.
I was never thinking
Stephen King credits nicotine with having a really strong effect on his
creativity and his a nerd,
you know,
neurons firing synapses firing because he said,
oh no,
he quit and he said it had a big change and you said,
uh,
yeah,
I said it was a lot harder after that.
The doctor will tell you that.
I said,
how long can I chew that gum forever?
Like I had a coach you in the Como cause it was pulling my crowns out.
Whoa.
It gets really hard after like 20 minutes.
But if you're a nicotine freak,
you're still chomping on it.
And then Mark Marin just keeps rotating them bitches with heartburn
retail.
It's me,
mark and Greg,
uh,
Canada hots,
Jeremy Hotz.
It's so,
it's always sounds the canary in the coal mine.
Who's the one that you guys watch?
It's like totally out of control.
Is it mark or is it Jeremy?
Well,
actually it's a Gregg Rogell Gregg Rogell with all out of the four of us.
I know,
I know.
Wherever I see that man anywhere on the planet at,
I threw him to the ground.
He has nicotine products on him somewhere.
I couldn't stay on.
It's either in his pockets or his back.
It's the way
I was flipping through the channels and a,
I saw him on one of those,
uh,
access TV live from Gotham things.
Yeah,
it was hilarious.
It's very funny.
His dear Saint [inaudible],
it's dues deuce.
It's a homage to letter is one of the funniest.
He won't do it hardly anymore,
but I begged them to do it at Macho.
He's one of those guys where I'm like,
how come people don't know who that guy is?
I don't know.
I couldn't agree more.
I see him when I go on national star.
He's hilarious.
And yet,
I don't know,
maybe I don't even know if he's doing it anymore.
Yeah.
While he was doing this access TV thing was really recent.
Well,
I also think he's not a big traveler.
Oh,
okay.
So he just likes to work in New York.
He's in the city a lot.
I don't,
does he have a regular job?
I don't know.
It's one of those guys.
He's,
he's kind of neurotic.
The conversations with Greg I have are usually about
the nicotine or art.
Just nothing.
Just nicotine or we don't talk.
It's like,
I dunno.
He's hard to reach.
He's not casual.
That's funny.
Intense.
Well,
he lives in New York,
right?
Yeah,
but I bet you if you looked online,
he doesn't have a,
I don't even know if he would have got a Wikipedia.
Does he?
Yep.
Professional comedian resides in New York City,
has appeared on the tonight show late night with Conan O'brien and the nanny.
He has had his own half hour special on comedy central and it was a feature
performer in the movie,
the aristocrats.
He's a regular performer at New York City's comedy cellar.
There you go.
[inaudible] powerful Gregg Gal.
I just want to say hi buddy.
Yeah,
I haven't seen you in awhile.
Come on out.
Gray.
Come out play region.
This the letter.
I'm going to read your Sandal.
Yeah,
he's a nice guy too.
Yeah.
Well we,
you did a,
you did last comic standing.
Yeah.
It was torture.
Who won that season?
Did you win?
No.
Have Fun.
Jeff.
Ron.
Yes.
Season two.
Yeah.
That was the one of the best seasons
I thought.
I really thought it was the best.
Not just cause I was on it cause the first season like a lot of comics didn't
try know everybody wanted to see what is it and they had,
they had some good people.
Uh,
then the second one and then the third one they just proceeded to ruin it and
then it just kept getting worse.
I'm like,
how could you take a show that has 13 million people in the summer,
the 13 million people and single handedly destroyed and they uh,
I mean it was working perfectly.
There's no reason that the comedians have to be hot.
They don't have to be young.
This is crazy.
It's comedy.
They should,
they just went so far off the rails.
I really think if somebody brought that back in the right way,
like you were saying,
it could be fixed.
There is no comedy in prime time.
Well I think we had the,
I don't think that's the move to bring that thing back.
Well not that,
but us.
Something like that where you're doing comedy,
right.
Kill Tony.
Why think that
the move would be to have,
uh,
some sort of a reality show with comedians.
Some,
some sort of an organized reality show.
What a bunch of funny people doing funny things so we could,
it can really be easily done when you just follow them around doing things
during the day.
You could have a funny show if you just figured out the right things for them to
participate in.
Get Joey Diaz,
Dunkin trusts on Arusha fear and send them to the race track.
You gotta find your show.
You gotta show it does.
You don't need a goddamn script.
I'd like to go with it and just start gambling the gambling people.
I want to go,
I mean,
that's a fucking show real easy.
That's a hit show.
And that show could be fucking hilarious if they would actually just let it
happen.
You know,
like,
just film it for a day.
It's going to be better than anything you write out and pretend you're working
in an office stop.
Yeah,
let's let us really gamble.
Let us,
you know,
let me and Lou and Ron White go golfing.
The good shit about that show was the comedians interacting with each other.
I mean,
that was like the best,
which was weird too because I thought that was another way they ruined it.
Like half those guys I already knew and liked.
I'm friends with Todd glass,
like these are my friends,
and they just kept saying,
well,
we need there to be drama and we need as well.
I'm not going to fight with people just to amuse you.
I'm not going to pick a fight with Todd.
Although Todd's such a good actor,
we could've pulled it off it to go,
okay,
but I go,
you have a tad,
then I'm going to look like this crazy bitch to America and I'm not so I'm not
going to,
it's not worth it.
It's not worth not for one episode two then that gets stuck in it,
you know?
No,
no,
no.
Not only that,
they don't give a fuck about you.
They will use you as a pawn to do this.
And they proved they didn't give a fuck about people the way they handle that
show in the first place where they didn't really let the comedians pick who the
performers were that actually made it through.
Right.
That's why I thought I'll never judge again.
Yeah,
I did as well.
It was a fake,
it was a fake judging and that's when,
uh,
Brett Butler and drew Carey walked off.
Oh yeah,
I remember that.
Yeah.
And we're like,
this is fake.
Like you're not,
we're not really judging you pretending we're judging there.
I mean,
we shouldn't even get into what was wrong with that show because there was so
much wrong with that show.
We could easily,
like,
you know,
there was a lot of issues.
Well,
here was my biggest issue.
Me and John have friends,
biggest issue,
no alcohol.
And that's hilarious.
No,
every other show I've ever seen.
Uh,
the Beverly housewives,
everybody's slamming drinks.
Yeah,
you get a good show and Martinis.
And so one of,
finally,
John and I complained enough.
I said,
first of all,
it was never in the contract that there would be no alcohol here.
You didn't tell me that.
Oh,
so it was not allowed.
No,
it was not on the property.
We had to live in this house for a month.
Comics,
but no alcohol.
That's so stupid.
Yeah.
And I don't even know about the pot people on that pop person.
So I don't know if they brought pot.
They probably brought it in their suitcase or something.
But had I been told I would have brought a case of wine or me and John would
have gotten a keg of something.
And so they brought in a six pack and they said,
fine,
you guys have bitched so much.
And with John to,
I
had one,
so there were three left,
woke up in the morning and they took him.
I'm like,
you can't even leave.
I was so excited.
The next day I'm like,
I'm going to have a beer by the fire.
I'm going to go get a beer.
I'm going to sit there and drink a beer and I go in the fridge.
I'm like,
fine.
They took.
Yeah.
That's a big problem in those shows is these ideas that these producers have
stuck in their head about how a show has to be and they just to get the best out
of people's personalities that are already performers.
You don't have to,
you'd have to arrange fake shit.
you know,
just let them blow him,
do things.
That was the problem with,
uh,
Lou had that show root of all evil on comedy central and we had the greatest
people,
uh,
Andy Kindler,
Greg Geraldo,
like you know,
all these guys that are super smart,
super funny,
and they just kept saying,
what has to be more scripted?
It has to be more scripted.
And why,
why,
why wouldn't you want Andy to just go off?
Like you had to say who is more evil?
Well,
they all have an idea in their head that's ancient there.
The idea in their head is it,
everything is scripted and you have to make sure that you control what the
content is.
He can't just let it be entertaining or not be entertaining.
That's why.
That's why I just,
I just sold my special to Netflix.
I will never,
talking to the networks is like talking your grandparents.
Really?
It is it.
Netflix is like,
you're cool young neighbor who knows all kinds of secret things you don't know
about.
There's super hip and you want to,
Eh,
keep asking him.
But I'm going to be like,
I'm bothering him and I'm crazy old lady in the neighborhood and Netflix,
they don't care.
I said,
is there any rules now?
Just go to your special,
here's a,
here's a boatload of money.
Yeah.
I did my first special with them and will not my first,
but my first DVD,
like 2005,
six not my first.
I had one before that,
but this was a better one,
2005 I did it with them and then sold to showtime.
Yeah,
they were awesome.
No problems.
Nobody calls.
There are very,
uh,
modern,
you know,
like showtime.
Okay.
So Kathleen know we're going to air your special on September 30th,
nine o'clock.
That's a premiere date.
Okay,
great.
And then how many times you're going to show it after that?
Uh,
we don't know what time would that be on a,
if you do,
I can't tell you.
If you find out,
we let me know.
No.
Okay.
Well you know what good is this?
I can't even tell anybody.
Netflix.
You just say,
Hey,
it's always on,
but the arrogance of the networks is what is going to kill them.
It's like,
do you understand that on a Netflix?
I can just turn on anything what I want it do you guys get that?
Like they don't,
they don't know the arrogance.
Assume that what they have is so special.
So CBS,
NBC,
Fox,
whatever.
They assume what they have is so special.
You're not going to duplicate that online,
but you're going to do a lot better than that online,
believe it or not,
way better.
Pretty soon
in anybody that is store that checks me out.
That's under the age of 30.
I go.
Do you have a TV?
No.
Have Tvs.
Yeah.
A lot of people these days know they go home and watch iPad cables,
experimental it.
Six months is over $70 a month or whatever.
Why would they?
They've gay get Hulu.
Netflix,
what else do you need on your iTunes?
Go download whatever you want.
It's like,
but it's as if the networks,
the big,
not showtime and Hbo as much,
but the CBS,
NBC,
they don't even know any of this exist.
Yeah,
that's how they speak in a meeting.
It's like you'd have to tell them,
well do you understand that on this channel?
Comedians can just do whatever they want.
No,
no.
Well they're starting to realize it.
They're starting to slowly realize that they're starting to wake up to Internet
content.
When when it starts like this,
see some of these youtube channels that people just create and then they see,
oh my goodness guys,
channel is 60 million people that have tuned into him just talking about shit
and you're like fuck.
And then you start doing,
they start realizing like,
oh wait,
what are we doing?
Like putting on these elaborate sets and like there's a lot of entertaining shit
that you're not even attempting because you have this rigid idea in your head of
what a,
a rigid old idea,
dumb old formula.
And like the USA Today the other day had all the new sitcoms coming out.
Bobo boom.
I mean it looked like a racing form and I thought,
you know,
90% of these won't make it.
You might as well just write garbage.
Uh,
monkey crab.
He Schmincke hot because none of this matters.
It won't be here cause it's all half of it.
At least half is total shit.
Yeah.
And then the stuff that isn't just total garbage,
what do you keep it a year or two?
It's fucking hard to put together a TV show.
Yeah,
it's fucking hard.
And there's a lot of people involved.
You know,
you're going to have to have a bunch of different people.
Satisfied.
Too many people.
That's why the Sitcom thing,
like when I see younger comics and that's what they want to do,
I'm like,
wow,
good news is you're young and if you want to spend a lifetime fighting with
these people too,
to get a TV show on,
but then even if you get it on,
it's gotta be a hit.
I did it and um,
I have never attempted it again.
I was like,
this is just a brutal,
it's just brutal.
Like we got it to a point where it was easy,
like news radio started out,
you know,
really long hours and took a while for the show to find its place.
But then once it got going,
we would only work sometimes two days a week or three days a week.
Like we would show up and do a run through on Friday or whenever the day before
we shot was,
we'd get the script then like that script problems,
like we would miss several days of rehearsal.
We just wouldn't do it.
He would get there and then we would figure it out within a day.
Fine.
Yeah,
it should be fine because we had it down to,
it would is a smooth oiled machine by then,
but in the beginning it's brutal.
The beginnings are horrible.
Just too many people.
Even at,
even at comedy central,
I remember I had written all this stuff and one of the executive ladies came
over and said,
I'll do take off.
Instead of saying gymnast Hera,
be Funnier if you said,
I don't know.
She threw out a word like giraffe or something.
And I go,
oh no,
uh,
I don't.
And she's like,
okay.
I go,
I'll do it if you want.
I'm tired of fighting.
I'm completely,
you've worn me down.
You,
when you want me to say Giraffe,
I'll say it,
but it's going to suck.
It's up to you.
They'll get upset too if you're not healthy,
you know,
meet us halfway here.
Okay.
How about draft gymnast?
How about gymnast?
Giraffe?
You can't even just throw it in there.
One of the arguments Doug and I had,
we were doing the man show is there was a show that we created called make me
hard.
And the show was,
you,
uh,
have a,
a box over a penis with a light bulb that goes off when you,
and it reads reason erection.
Obviously we control the light bulb.
So it's like Maajid Banana,
bananas,
things along those lines gives you these incredible boners.
And um,
they didn't,
they had no problem with,
we had a trainee,
uh,
I should say transgender,
excuse me,
partying.
My trainee friends,
they get upset with that word.
Um,
and the,
the,
the Gig was that this guy had this box on his penis.
Let's see what really gets them hard.
Um,
we had to all these hot girls in front of him dancing,
nothing.
And this other hot girl comes over and he starts sucking lip cream off our
breasts.
Like everybody's going crazy.
Then she pulls her pants off Chesapeake Ines and everybody goes fucking bananas.
Like it's the like the loudest,
oh my.
Ah,
you've ever heard from 200 audience members?
They didn't have any problem with that,
but the word hard is just too much.
Well,
yeah,
they wanted it to be called make me stiff and you know,
so we're in the art.
We were in this argument and Doug and I are just sitting there going,
I don't even understand what you're saying here.
You're saying that we can have a transgender person whipped their Rivard cock
out.
I mean,
it was a cock that had been suffered three years of a female hormones.
So this cog was just barely,
and it was,
it was,
it was a sad,
sad cock.
That's okay,
but you can't say hard like you're,
you're allowing this guy to unknowingly suck whipped cream off a man's tits.
He doesn't even know.
And everybody's okay with that.
Then he whips out his penis and then you're okay with that too.
This guy's going to be humiliated by this,
I'm sure.
Or you know,
he obviously,
he was a good sport.
He thought it was hilarious,
but that's okay.
It's a long time ago.
I want to,
I did the tonight show at one of the,
one of the sets on there,
and I had a joke with a setup was kids are like homeless people.
And they go,
could you,
uh,
could you not say homeless people?
I go,
the jokes not about homeless.
People listen to the joke,
it's about kids and,
and they go,
ah,
maybe just say,
a Hobo.
I go,
well,
here,
it's a problem.
I'm not a comic from the 18 hundreds.
Fucking Hobo Volvo.
Then they came back.
Hobos a great word.
I love Hobo.
It just didn't fit.
And then,
then they came back with why no,
I go,
so it's okay to make fun alcoholics,
but homeless people,
they are homeless that I'm not judging,
right.
It's what they are.
I just a fine,
what's the context?
How's the rest of the big,
uh,
it was to,
don't judge who was a long,
long time ago.
I don't,
kids are like,
ah,
I don't have kids.
My sister's got kids.
If they're not yours,
you realize what kids really are.
A dark,
dark,
tiny homeless people.
There's chase you around the house,
all the land going,
hey,
can I have a dollar?
Hey food,
I'm missing a shoe and I need a ride.
Hey,
can I have a ride?
Okay.
It's silly.
It's stupid.
And that's where they,
they just lost their mind over the word homeless.
Well then,
because I then I said,
uh,
I always give homeless people money and maybe you shouldn't.
My brother goes,
don't,
he's just going to go buy more alcohol and cigarettes.
And I go,
oh,
like I wasn't,
so I'm bringing,
it's still back to me.
So making fun of me,
right.
I go,
so what am I supposed to say?
Don't give that wine.
Oh,
money.
Yeah.
Why?
You know a Hobo?
I'm sorry,
I don't have any material about riding the rails.
Well,
Kathleen,
we've done some poles and people are very uncomfortable with the word homeless.
Yeah,
I guess so.
Yeah.
It's not funny.
Okay.
The are victims involved here and it's not funny,
but fuck wine.
Okay.
It's a societal problem that we're trying to work through and we those mocking
it.
Yes.
Why knows like the softest version of alcoholic too?
It's like they're not even drinking whiskey.
No,
it's fine.
Wine.
Okay.
Someone has a great taste for wine.
It got a little out of hand
and had him Hawaii.
No.
Too many bottles a night.
It was fine when it was a glass
somewhere along the line.
Assad pleasure in that bottle.
I sought freedom and release Nama.
Why?
No.
Hm.
Yeah,
I think,
well also I said,
you know,
Hobo,
was it a life choice?
Yes.
There were people that just chose to ride the rails.
Maybe they like to travel.
I don't know why they did it,
but was it depression too?
I think there's a great book that I read about a guy named,
it was,
I think the book's called McGurty.
It's a life of a pool hustler in the,
during the depression.
And this guy,
uh,
traveled all over the country and like you oftentimes they were starving the
begging people for food,
but they were trying to like gamble and each town like,
I'll stop blowing away because there was no jobs and there was nothing for young
men to do.
Like it was desperate times and some people just did whatever the hell they
could to do it.
Fat,
fascinating book.
I feel like Hobos,
uh,
we're doing more things to like homeless.
I just picture Santa Monica promenade sign,
you know,
ask him for money.
Hobos,
I felt like were active.
They were building fires or riding trains.
Yeah.
This is the book.
It's called Mcgourty,
a poolroom hustler.
And uh,
I wrote it,
it's an interesting book.
It's all this guy telling his whole life story about what it was like,
you know,
like traveling on the rails and being a hobo and you know,
begging for food.
Yeah.
Like at least he has enough to write and alive because he traveled.
He did met friends.
He gambled like homeless.
Just implies to me kind of hanging around.
Right.
They're not really.
Um,
but speaking of,
uh,
crazy weird people.
Have you guys seen this story today?
Today?
I saw it about the clown.
One clown in North Hampton.
Yeah.
There's this clown.
This is going around fucking freakiest thing ever.
North Hampton,
Massachusetts,
as scary as it is in England.
I think you're right.
I think it was North Hampton.
It's this clown that's been terrorizing.
Oh,
it's an English town.
So yeah,
it's an England.
England,
yeah,
North Hampton clown.
Terrorizes English town.
And it's so scary.
Photos of this fucking,
yeah,
it looks like.
Can you put up,
yeah.
It doesn't speak English.
It doesn't juggle and has balloons,
but doesn't hand them out.
It probably doesn't even sleep,
but just stand there haunting our dreams with that sinister smile.
Anonymous.
Matt has been stocking fear,
striking fear into the hearts of Hampton UK community by ominously standing
around in a creepy clown and creepy clown apparel.
Wow.
Yeah.
He looks like the the the,
the Stephen King a clown.
This position is super scary.
I don't know why,
but like it's relieving to came home and that guy was in your driveway.
I would immediately turn around and drive straight to the police department
station.
Like that's crazy.
And then apparently doesn't he?
He either,
I don't know think he tweets,
but I think he has a Facebook page.
Yeah.
That's like you don't really end up,
they don't know who it is.
It's just he talks his him and he's like,
I'm not going to harm any weight.
Anyone.
Okay.
Off to go outside.
Beep beep,
like wrote on Facebook.
No,
I don't have a knife on me.
I just want to be spotted.
Wow.
You know what man?
This photo and his Facebook page is from Stephen King's it.
That's what somebody is saying.
I just,
yeah,
yeah.
So there,
is that what you just said?
Yeah,
that is from it.
I remember that movie.
Who played the the,
was it Leguizamo?
Oh No.
Was it Leguizamo that played?
No.
Tim.
Someone I'm playing Stephen King's at.
Who the fuck played at?
Tim Conway did?
No,
come over here.
Remember Tim Conway had all those fucking videos about golf,
about a guy with no legs.
Like what the fuck it was Dorothy.
Dorothy fuck wrong with America.
That that was on like late night TV infomercials every night in woop.
Woops,
boom.
And he'd fall over and they'll sell phony.
They couldn't get going to wait to get the next door if on golf video.
What the fuck was that?
I don't remember.
Started on the show,
I think on a Johnny Carson.
Was it trend?
No,
I think it started on a,
Oh,
maybe it didn't with Mrs. Wiggins with the second
Terry.
Yeah.
Uh,
whatever the Carol Burnett show.
Yeah,
it was,
I bet it started as a sketch.
Oh,
it Dorf on that and then
he,
he off,
you know,
routed.
Okay.
Tim Curry.
Tim,
the guy from rocky horror picture show,
he was the clown that's even creepier man already creepy to be thing,
but then bought North Hampton's clown.
That's what he calls himself,
calls himself spot.
He's answering questions,
he's doing like question answering.
See you all very soon.
BP became wow.
Okay,
let's see how come the cops kick get his address off that computer and go over
and say,
I guess what is the crime?
Is he committing though?
Isn't it really gearing up the guys finding so much attention from this?
I bet he's probably,
if I had a guest and uh,
I would love to,
I would say I see is a borderline or ready to fucking blow a gasket and go full
postal.
Yeah guys handing out fucking waves.
Just dressed up like a clown standing there and they're like,
apparently he stood across the street from neighbors and just stared at their
house for like three hours in that position.
I might bring that guy with a baseball bat.
Sometimes there's not time for law.
Sometimes you just,
everybody's smashed the city cameras and dragged back into the forest or he's
just promoting a shitty band or something stupid like that down.
Crazy guy,
man.
Could you imagine if that was like the beginning of their music video and then
they just had this guy to do this for days and days and days.
So writing and huff and it's,
well actually one direction,
one direction
and the clown terrorizes them.
It chases them around their music video I splashed through a pool.
Bare chested.
They're not even reaching puberty yet.
This sleek.
How much went to week listening to Joe Zero just learned about it a couple of
days ago.
I didn't know.
I knew there was going to be a new one.
You know,
it's just a matter of time for it.
Adoption toys becomes in sync,
becomes this,
becomes that.
I knew there's going to be a new one,
but I wasn't aware.
I don't think these boys are that cute though and they can't do,
oh,
how dare you?
How dare you?
They're very cute.
Do you remember Donny Walberg?
Jesus Christ dairy?
I don't.
No,
no,
no.
Google it.
They don't want to shit on these.
Poor young man.
Poor little cuties.
Are they all British?
How long has this fucking clown been doing this?
Does anybody know?
I just saw the story today.
I don't know how long,
but this is what,
okay.
I'm a big fan of the discovery id channel in line and let's see.
Oh,
they're fine.
They have all those crackers,
chips Ahoy and crackers.
They're selling cookies.
I don't know man.
That's awesome.
Okay.
The one on the end.
It's really cute.
They're all about the music and the Ritz.
They're all about selling crackers.
You can still look cool and so crackers dude,
isn't that weird?
Products look at the products they sell their products aren't they?
Are they probably created by by who?
Like chips Ahoy Warner brothers or something.
Quite focus on a dude's package back.
Oh,
I was stuck at the blind sheikh off.
I know you're doing captain supplemental package.
Young boy package man.
You're very one direction sensitive.
What dare you call me on that.
Especially the live,
so you don't know about the smell.
But on the,
I watch a lot of the ID channel and they have a whole series called stocked and
when you see what you can get away with that it not being a crime,
this clown could,
has a lot of room left to go before he's doing anything legally wrong.
Really.
You just stand right in front of someone's house and stare at them and do it
now.
Yeah.
Some lady had this guy and it wasn't like an ex boyfriend.
It was just this crazy person.
And she would call the cops and he'd be right across on the other sidewalk and
they'd go,
we can do it's public property.
We can't make him stop it,
do anything.
So clown guy,
you know,
he could keep going and going,
I think the Facebook page.
So now you've created an identity for your identity.
Like you're taking it at another layer.
I would go visit his house to make sure there weren't,
uh,
bodies in the basement.
It's too challenging.
Gacy too.
Yeah.
Well,
it's the fact that it's Facebook page has,
it has the Tim Curry version of Stephen King's
character.
Yeah.
It's mean it's not a happy creepy.
The v the whole look is creepy.
Like that's a person who's trying to intimidate.
Yeah.
Freak people.
Totally freak people out and it's working.
Or it's of a music video.
It could be,
yes,
probably the last couple of months.
And then next thing you'll see the see the boys dancing and spinning around in
the clouds to con tries to kidnap them maybe as rope,
but he keeps missing him with the robe.
Maybe he's the new map.
A new member.
Yeah.
They want to make it a little bit more accessible to people that like clowns.
Sure.
I'll hit right in the middle of that picture in a director's chair.
Come on.
So that band actually does that.
How's this band get made?
Is this is as a corporation gets together and they say,
we're just going to get a bunch of cute guys.
Yeah,
we're going to get a bunch of songs.
It's suck and we're going to make you sing them and they're going to be all
about love.
And the next thing you know,
you've got a Ferrari
who's,
yeah.
Who's in Emba fuckers.
If you're going to be completely crazy.
Oh,
for raising.
Yeah.
You were staying at some hotel and I went to the hotel to go to their spa,
uh,
to get a pedicure and I wa I,
I didn't know one direction was there.
There must have been.
I can't,
I don't know,
2000 girls outside the hotel screaming their name.
Wow.
Thought.
Okay.
I'm still out of it.
Yeah.
Those are girls that don't even know what they're going to do with them when
they get them.
That's what's hilarious.
It's not like these girls later to fuck,
they're like eight.
No.
Like,
oh my God.
Oh my God.
Like they don't even know what's happening and their parents are bringing them
there.
They're the hard curls.
Oh my goodness.
It's screaming,
cheering.
They don't even know what they're actually setting up.
Well,
I don't,
I just liked the idea of when you get,
um,
like,
like you got one and he gets in your car,
it goes home with you.
Could you imagine got direction
if one of those girls who was in love with one of those guys and the guy was
just kind of nutty and he's like,
look,
I'll go home with you guys.
You really like me.
Come on,
take me to home.
I'll have dinner with you.
And so the one direction guys like sitting across the table from the eight year
old and the eight year olds freaking out,
what,
what difference does it make?
Like what are you actually doing here?
Are you just trying to meet this guy or are you trying to fuck him and you're
eight years old,
you know you can't fuck guys.
Like why you doing,
what do you want out of getting
I come,
I got,
was she screaming and cheering from?
I think if you,
what do you want one and put it in front of the eight year old girl should
freeze up.
Oh yeah.
It would just be over her probably kidneys would fail something serious,
whatever gotten,
if I would've gotten this close to Sean,
Cassie,
I might've fainted
so happy together.
Was that him?
No,
no,
it wasn't as to do Ron.
Ron To do run run.
Yeah.
I remember David more than I remember Sean.
Yeah,
sure.
I liked him better.
He was the underdog because he was blind.
He was the blonde one in Sean wasn't in the TV show that much.
He was not in the sh no,
he wasn't that at all.
He was in the hardy boys with Parker Stevenson.
He became really huge too.
Well,
he's more sane.
He's a director now and David's kind of off the rails,
the new show comics hanging out with David Cassidy.
He does some of the same show,
the a new show couple Cominos,
David Cassidy.
What went wrong?
David build the houses,
the houses of one direction.
He had a big thing in Vegas for a while.
Didn't he have a big Gig?
Not a big Gig,
but a Gig,
but I thought it was a big one.
I thought it was a pretty big gig because I think someone else had it and then
he had it for a while and maybe I'm not so crazy the that it didn't work out.
Didn't work.
No,
it didn't work.
I read some great stories about him though.
He just got a Dui like two weeks ago was in all the stuff two weeks ago.
David,
how dare you.
You should have learned by now.
Nobody's Duis better recently than Al Michaels.
What happened without Michael Monica Al Michaels?
I mean this is because of a joke of my art.
The when you're rich and famous should major drinking you driving,
blah,
blah.
But Al Michaels go is hammered.
Santa Monica comes upon a Dui checkpoint freaks out and does an illegal u turn
in front of the checkpoint and speeds away
the hope of four hours.
We just played right into their hand like fuck.
They usually just go right,
right?
Yeah.
I mean that end they got him,
they got one.
You a mug shot a fucking owl,
bro.
What happened buddy?
Yes.
Yeah.
Does he do that?
It's more Robert.
More.
Yeah.
Al Is football guy.
He's a football and I'll talk a hockey guy.
How hammered was he?
Uh,
I don't remember.
He blew a [inaudible] say
David Katz.
The arrested on suspicion of drunk driving in New York August 21st so yeah,
it was really recently.
Yeah.
One time teen dream.
And the Partridge family star was arrested Wednesday morning just after midnight
in
upstate New York.
Cassidy 63 was initially pulled over.
No.
Yeah,
he was initially pulled over for driving with his high beams on Tmz reported and
the officer does administered the field sobriety test after smelling alcohol.
The actor singer did poorly on the sobriety test and showed a blood alcohol
level of zero point 10.
It's just a little bit over drunk.
Right.
He was cuffed and jailed or Ma Ma Ma Ma.
I don't really think he was previously arrested a Dui in Florida in 2010 yeah,
happening a lot.
Yeah.
Dash Cam footage showing him failing a field sobriety test and the officer
finding an open bottle of Bourbon in the car.
Oh,
that's hardcore.
Yeah.
He changed his mind and pleaded to a no contest.
Oh,
Sally.
David,
I guess it's fucking hard for those people,
those teen throbs that become,
boy,
you remember the show a man,
while the way politically incorrect used to be when it was on,
uh,
not comedy central,
then it went somewhere else.
I want,
I did an episode with Dick Van Patton and he had read a book how to make your
child a star.
Right?
Creepy,
right.
And Bill Maher,
I'll,
it was me,
uh,
Dick Van Patten,
somebody and Queen Latifa,
I don't remember.
And Dick Van Patten was so out of his mind,
he was screaming,
uh,
whoever was sitting next to me was saying,
this is terrible.
You shouldn't write books like this.
These kids all end up crazy.
It's almost like Dick van Patten has been prepared for this.
And he goes,
I have a list of people that are completely sane.
Rodney Howard.
And he starts spitting out all these names of child stars that went on to not
become crazy.
Right.
But his list wasn't that long.
Jody foster?
Uh,
yeah.
I'm trying to remember.
It's on the amount of,
mostly actors from way back,
like not now.
Like,
good.
It must be so crazy to have something happen to you early in life,
like becoming a David Cassidy type guy where you're this enormous star.
You're like a young,
young,
young guy and you'll never hit that height again.
So all of a sudden it goes away and just living a normal life,
which is like fine for most of us just living a normal life,
right?
But living a normal life is like a torture.
Like,
like,
yeah,
you didn't,
you don't,
you didn't make it.
Huh?
Look at you.
It gets you go,
went away.
Huh?
Hey,
are you the guy from hey,
yeah,
go you hanging around with us.
There was this a really douchey guy that works at the cvs in my house.
He's just really angry Middle East and dude,
I don't know what his deal is.
He's a weird guy.
And uh,
one time I was there and uh,
I was,
I'm paying for something and he goes,
it will happen to your show.
What would you show?
And I go,
what?
You know,
I was playing stupid.
He goes,
this show you had,
what happened to it?
I go,
I don't know what happened to it.
He
goes,
this is not on,
no,
I mean more like,
dude,
you're working at fucking cvs and we really having this argument,
man,
let me pay for my fucking candy bar winner.
Yeah,
you win.
My show's not on TV anymore.
Are you fucking paying attention on t v Jesus Christ dickhead.
It was just,
it's a weird guy like,
but people like to do that.
The elected.
Oh,
look at you.
I'm not doing a thing.
Went away.
Huh?
I think he got canceled all the movie didn't do so good.
Oh,
that movie dude.
It wasn't so good.
Huh?
I heard that movie didn't do so good.
You're not so tall.
Short guy.
Little tiny guys.
I've got a fat face.
You meet a lot of food or what do you eat?
Bad food.
He would,
he would drink a lot that's going on with you.
And the money goes away too.
If you're David Cassidy,
the attention goes away and now the money is gone.
I've tried to think of the casino.
We,
uh,
we all did it,
in Vegas.
They're very nice people.
It's all the way down at the end though,
it's not really connected.
Uh,
Green Valley ranch station,
casino,
no s all the way at the end.
All the way to the end.
Red Rock.
No squirting pass lux or keep going past all that bitch.
No sparks
walk it.
Give me your money.
Silly Bitch.
That's my new Casino Swan.
Like Oh yeah,
I dunno.
Sahara.
No,
no,
no.
You're going the wrong way.
Oh,
the other way to know what's where.
I'm not start us star five star fire.
No circus circus.
They have a room.
It's probably a 500 seater and David Cassie was involved there.
Okay.
Yeah,
that makes sense.
Yeah.
These guys like they always have a career,
right?
They could always like get gigs.
45 year old women that will always go see David Cassidy further long trip down
memory lane.
Oh,
he's still kind of cute.
Fuck him.
I'll just dim the lights.
Take a Xanax off.
Fuck.
'Em just to put it on the bucket.
Cassidy.
I don't know.
Um,
I don't,
Shit on David's class is going to happen to Justin Bieber.
I mean,
come on.
I remember when Gary Coleman was working as a security guard and it was like
this fucking big thing.
They would,
people would go and goof on them and take pictures with them.
You know,
guys,
just trying to make a living.
One of one of the cleavers became a cop while the cleavers like for cleaver
beaver.
Yeah.
He might be the cleavers account.
Remember when the dude from the love boat became a senator,
congressman,
congressman or senator.
What one was hungriness congressman.
Yeah.
Who was that from the love boat though.
Yes.
Bernie something.
Alright.
Love Boat Congress.
The glasses.
He kind of looked like a Mitch McConnell type,
but not that other Fred granddaddy.
Fred.
Yeah.
There he is.
Remember the US House of Representatives from Iowa?
Gary Coleman as a security guard.
Yeah.
That shit man.
Oh yeah.
There he is.
The saddest shit was a,
the wife that he had that took the photos of him dying,
I was off of feeding tubes.
She put it took a Selfie of her in front of the feeding tubes.
Fucking evil.
Just,
those are the people that you get attached to and you know,
where was he a security guard at a lot like cvs or something.
I forget something along those lines.
I mean,
how badly is that career managed though?
I mean it's Gary Coleman.
You can get them on something.
It's parents stole from it in there.
Yeah.
That's a super common thing that parents steal from people.
Man.
You could at least on porn.
Oh Brian,
that's not an at least sometimes you're better off just becoming a security
guard.
Okay.
Yeah.
And letting a bunch of dudes fuck you.
Why is it going to be too?
Cause that's where the real money is.
The real money from male performers.
Let's be realistic.
The real money from me
farmers is not in pitching and catching,
um,
be normal.
He's not,
he's not a congressman anymore.
Let's say quit.
Do you not get reelected?
He's still alive.
65 but it says a 1995 he was in office from a 87 to 95.
Huh?
Maybe it was like this.
Fucking people are too crazy
doing better than David Cassidy.
Maybe drinking and walking.
True drinking and not leaving the house.
I didn't get this role.
It's Iowa,
it's called outlets.
Yeah.
I drink and shoot deer out his window
hours.
I fucking Congress,
man.
I love the lab
and that's a thing people love to like stick in people's face,
you know?
Yeah.
You're using the TV.
Worse than a failure because at least like a regular failure.
Like,
you know,
if you're a guy and you're,
I'm just sweeping up on the street,
that's one thing.
But if you're Warren Beatty and you're sweeping up in the street,
you used to be Warren Beatty right
in.
They're all in from now.
You've got a push broom.
You,
it's not just a regular guy.
It's like,
oh,
you see,
be privileged.
He's too one of the elite.
Now look at you.
I'm above you.
Or was that guy still at your cvs?
Um,
no,
I haven't seen them in awhile.
I think you've probably got fired.
Guy Was a deck,
but I had interactions with him a couple of times.
It was like,
there was a couple like odd ones,
but that one was like real specific.
Like he just started like quiz,
like you couldn't help himself.
He was quizzing me on my my where is your show?
Not on anymore.
Huh?
Why?
What is your pent up anger about what it was?
At least your cvs has employees.
Mine.
It's a free for all.
I mean it seriously like I think I could just,
if there weren't cameras just walk right out with shit.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
I mean I don't even want to,
I want to pay.
There's no one to pay the job men
do at night.
Do you do it at like late it and neither will usually 24 hours a day,
right?
No,
I don't go the one on all by my house.
Creepy.
I wouldn't go there at night.
There's just Harold people piss and everywhere and it's not good
to go to a pharmacies.
24 pharmacies really late at night.
Like sometimes like when I'm coming home from a Gig,
if I notice that the place is open and it's like 2:00 AM what's your shoe is up,
I'll park the car and go wander around.
Well,
no,
because you see weird people and you see some weird shit go down at these these
places because it's one of the only things open.
So usually it's people,
a lot of people that are cranked up and we're fucked up or drunk or something.
And so like sometimes when you go through them,
like you'll see some shit,
you'll see something that's interesting.
You see some weird people.
I did see,
uh,
at the CVS late.
It was,
it was Paul,
not too late.
It was nighttime though,
probably eight,
eight o'clock and the pharmacy was still open and this gigantic drag queen
trying.
See,
I tried to return medicine.
I thought this was the best reason.
Every slammed a door.
Then he goes,
I'm on my Mac.
This medicine didn't work.
And The lady's like,
uh,
sir,
ma'am,
whatever we can't take back opened used medicine.
Why not?
It don't work.
And I thought,
wow,
he does have a point of it,
right?
I don't know what he was supposed to do.
Maybe it was supposed to make them a lady faster.
I don't know what
medication was,
but clearly it didn't calm him down.
And he is not achieved the results he wants.
I think you should be held to give it back.
Tick.
Dissolver
yeah,
I don't think,
I don't think you're the proper protocol surely have established protocols
for this poor pharmacists lady.
Like,
like,
I need this crap at nine o'clock call for a manager.
There isn't one.
You might as well just call the cops at that point.
There's no managers and cvs.
I mean if they are,
they don't come out in the public eye and they're also working the cash
register.
Yeah.
To teach me how to use the cash register.
Now they're teaching me how to use the self checkout.
I don't want to use the self checkout.
You're here.
You do it.
I like the self checkout.
I love it.
It feels very space to me.
Like you don't even have to talk to people.
Just pick some stuff up and you'd scan it and then you run a credit card and you
don't talk to a person.
Uh,
yeah.
But uh,
nicotine patches.
You got it.
Oh,
you need a person.
Someone's got a problem by that shit.
A little on someone needs some drugs.
It's,
yeah.
Somebody needs to make money.
Yeah.
Why don't you buy it on Amazon so much cheaper at Amazon.
Are you serious?
Listen,
when are these people going to learn about the internet?
I know you don't even know about amazon.com yeah,
no Amazon buy things from it.
I wouldn't think they'd sell nicotine.
They sell everything that exists.
I Buy,
I do maybe 70% of my shopping on amazon.com I'm not bullshit.
And not to mention La is when the most unique cities that has Amazon fresh now,
which is a app that you download that consent groceries to your house,
like,
like next day or even earlier than that sometimes where you just order all your
groceries
on an app and they come right to your house and drop it off.
Why don't you Google how long that actually takes instead of saying or maybe
even closer some times.
Well,
let's find out.
Yeah,
I mean there's no need to not find out.
When you say something like that,
you should always Google it instead of just panicking.
That's why I covered my house.
Well,
I Google it bitch.
I think a bit grocery stores you can,
some of them like pavilions you can send in an order and then grocery.
So he kind of got to pick them out.
Yeah.
Well yes.
Some people that are like super,
uh,
you know,
wealthy and live in New York,
they do that as well.
Like in New York City,
that's like you can't fucking drive.
Where are you going to go to get groceries,
right.
They have to walk to get groceries.
So,
and then you gotta walk home like Jesus Christ and what are you going to do?
Right.
You're going to bring your own grocery cart.
Well,
yeah,
they don't get knocked.
What do they do?
They're not getting bags out either same or next day.
Same or next day.
Nice.
Yeah.
See like living in New York City,
that would be one of the big bombers is that you can't just go drive to the
grocery store and then come home and pull into the driveway and unloaded like a
fucking human,
right.
You have to live in this gigantic cage stacked up on top of each other.
We have to venture out on foot,
like a fucking caveman and hunt and gather your food,
bring it back to the cave.
It only works for people like,
like Lou loves restaurants.
He just loves to eat out.
So like New York is perfect for him.
Louis Black.
Yeah.
He's a foodie.
Right?
Oh dear.
Hey.
Like you know it new restaurants opening up,
he can't wait.
He knows he is a Zagat guide.
He's a walking Manhattan Zagat Guide.
So he's uses in his pig heaven.
Oh yeah.
Makes mixed sound like,
I don't even think he would understand how to drive to the grocery store,
buy bags of it and then bring it home.
Really?
Yeah.
He's too much into that.
But I,
it bothers me.
That's why I won't live there.
I mean I constantly going out to eat well and I don't like even like my house,
like I don't,
I don't want to get,
I never wanted a house with gates and all and I want to be able to just walk
onto my front porch and go on my house and then walk out the back door and be in
a backyard.
You live in la?
The La area?
Yeah.
This is this a good thing about living in la.
There's too many God damn people.
But you do get some space at least.
Yeah.
There's plenty of space for what your money compared to,
I could sell the house here and flip with Lou and what has to be a little bit
more,
but it's way smaller.
Yeah.
And then you know,
it's an elevator.
I feel like I'm in a hotel,
like he's selling an apartment.
Yeah.
And they're cool with that.
People that live in hotels are living,
you know,
apartments.
They're cool with that.
Like they don't,
they don't have any problem with living on the 80th floor.
No,
not at all.
He's done in his whole life.
No car.
And I said,
what if like no car?
What it has?
It had a car in 25 years.
I go,
what if,
uh,
I had a heart attack it or lamb.
It's too extreme.
Maybe something you can't drive me to the hospital so we just go hail a cab.
You know Amy Lou,
I mean,
uh,
hardest.
Heck you'd call nine one one,
but then how long is it going to take them to get here?
Where are they going to park?
Yeah.
I thought it's not for me.
Uber,
all my heart attacks.
I'm two minutes late.
You could always Uber,
um,
to Midwest.
Even golf.
Like he has his golf clubs in some storage unit and then we have to get the golf
clubs and either there's a town car that he'll pay for or we take the subway or
dragon golf clubs.
Right.
It's crazy.
I'll be like,
this is too much.
Too much.
He takes,
he has a storage unit where he puts his shit.
A lot of his extra stuff.
Yeah.
Can't keep it all in his little apartment.
And his apartment for New York is actually quite,
well.
It's one bedroom wall,
an office and a big deck.
The deck is probably as big as the actual apartment,
which is awesome,
but he can't store everything up there.
No Way.
And so he has a storage unit and then does he have a crazy view?
We have to walk down.
Oh,
he has a really good view.
He's not too high though.
He's the top of,
it's only I think seven floors.
Oh yeah.
So he's not,
it's a great circular view.
You're not looking down on this city.
You're,
you're right in.
He's like surrounded by all these big buildings.
You're almost like in a vortex.
That's kind of cool too.
I like it.
Yeah,
I like that looking at the other,
but there's no view like that.
You know,
every time I stay in New York and I take pictures of like out the window of the
hotel room,
I always like,
this is no view like this.
This is such a weird view.
It's so crazy.
All these giant ass fucking building stacked in on top of each other.
It's such an odd point.
Sun,
like other big cities in the world,
like Paris,
there's always sun because the buildings are short.
Right.
Roam the building.
New York,
everything is so high.
Light doesn't come in,
which I never thought I even cared about light until it was taken away.
Do you think you live like in Seattle?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
I love it up there,
but do you think you could deal with the winter then?
The no light?
Yeah,
the,
yeah.
Yeah.
Rain,
love rain.
We were just talking about that because the direct TV and my brother goes
terrible.
Right?
The under stores,
they said,
we'll sadly,
there are none in la.
He's in the Midwest and I go there.
That's the thing.
I miss the most funders.
There's no thunderstorms here or even just a gloomy day.
Yeah.
There's never a where you feel like it's okay to be lazy
funder at night when you're sleeping.
Yeah.
It sounds cool.
Right?
It's like it's the law.
The skies alive.
Yeah.
I didn't even know what's under it was until I watched your show.
You didn't know why?
No.
Wow.
That's funny.
I've made it through the entire Missouri school system and I was never told
that.
I didn't understand that it was the ions of the lightning being released.
And you could count by seconds of how far that lightning strike is.
So that one,
yeah,
you got one Mississippi,
two men.
If it's three,
that's three miles away.
Yeah,
seriously.
Yeah.
Really?
Yeah,
something like that.
It's not an exact obviously,
but yeah,
there's a,
there's a
way to,
just a way to actually tell,
like if you have a stopwatch,
you know there's a way to actually judge it.
Mississippi.
Just make that up.
Yeah,
that's,
no,
there really is a formula.
Like if you had a stop light on your phone,
I'm sure your phone has a watch and a stopwatch,
you press the stop watch feature,
right when you see the lightning [inaudible] then when the boom had,
so you just calculate the seconds and you know how far away it is.
Oh,
I see.
It's the best thing to tell a child,
by the way,
because as a kid living in Ohio,
I was so scared of lightning and thunder and shit like that.
So my dad told me that and so like I would see this bright flash of light and
that one too.
You like to see how far it was?
Well it's crazy when you hear one,
it's like 30 seconds away.
Yeah.
And you can see it.
I mean you could see a giant ass bolt of lightning 30 seconds away,
30 miles away.
It's wow.
Crazy
sees lightening I've ever seen was in Iraq because there was a sand storm.
So,
and a lot of the sands,
you don't see it.
It's weird.
I took pictures with my camera and I'm like,
man,
it's just camera already broken.
Cause there were dots,
right?
Nighttime pictures and there's dots.
I'm like,
I thought maybe I got it wet.
And they're like,
the soldier guys were like,
no,
that's sand.
I go,
I don't see it with my naked eye.
He goes,
you,
you don't,
he goes,
wait till you see a thunderstorm.
The lightning,
I don't know anything about science,
but somehow it connects with all these sand particles.
So the lightening is like a spiderweb.
Whoa man.
Alright.
It's freaky.
Weird storm.
Yeah,
I know.
And probably the Middle East.
The heat has something to do with it too.
How long did you go to Iraq for?
Uh,
uh,
we could go two weeks at a time when we and Afghanistan and all.
How many times have you gone?
Twice.
I'm done now.
I've retired from the military.
Yeah.
What happened?
I keep my boots back.
I just can't,
I can't,
I can't do it again.
I mean it would really have to be a major request.
It's just there's something wrong over there.
Yeah.
You don't feel right when you get home.
We got weird skin things.
Lou Leica,
his skin started all rotting off right here,
but bizarrely enough,
it looked exactly like a Hitler mustache.
He got off the plane,
got to Hitler disease,
he dead.
He got,
and I said,
that's weird because you're Jewish.
You have the Hitler mustache and the hat up.
What do you think you got that from the air there?
It's polluter or something.
I don't know if it was
the air and then I got this thing here on my face.
What'd you get at like the swelling?
That wouldn't go away for no reason.
I thought maybe it was like,
God,
do I get bitten by like a sand flea or,
right.
Uh,
and the military always just says,
oh,
well,
we don't know.
We don't think it has anything to do with here.
Just weird things.
Just,
just not necessarily to go.
I feel like I did it to twice.
That was enough.
Is that what it looks like?
You're supposedly,
uh,
yes.
Holy Shit.
That's in night vision.
It's even crazier.
It looks like a rave.
Like,
yeah,
it looks amazing.
And then when you're like,
blah,
camera's not
great.
Great.
The way it connects with the particles,
almost like instead of a bolt,
it looks like a spiderweb.
Oh Wow.
That looks amazing.
Super Freaky.
And we were there in winter.
I can only imagine what it's like in the summer when it's 130.
It's probably even more spectacular.
But then I think,
well why doesn't that happen in Vegas?
But they don't have sand storms per se in Vegas.
Not like they do know the Vegas will stand.
Storms aren't shit compared to what?
To the Middle East.
Where,
I mean the sky is orange from sand,
sand orange.
It's like an orange out two times.
We couldn't buy anywhere for the entire day.
They were like,
yeah,
network.
No one could go anywhere.
Helicopters can't go up.
It depends.
But the,
the ones we got into lasted a day,
a whole day though of just,
it's like the moon,
like people shouldn't be living there.
It's crazy.
Or are like the guys that used to just travel with their little
tents and camels and roam around.
Maybe they knew the deal.
Like a sandstorm coming,
let's get out.
But to plant yourself there,
I think you're asking for problems.
Yeah.
It's not a good spot.
Look at that.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
Very much.
Lightening Bolt through sand is Christ.
It's incredible.
It does.
It interacts with all the sand particles.
Yeah.
And there's billions of them,
which are,
you can see on my camera.
So when you asked about the,
the,
the skin things that you guys are both have and they,
they didn't think that they're related,
is that what they said?
Well,
I didn't even know if they were related either.
I'd,
I didn't have a Hitler mustache and he didn't have any swelling.
Uh,
uh,
and we,
he was doing gigs that he came out here and he's like,
we take me to a dermatologist.
I said,
funny enough,
I have to go to,
there's something in my face.
And then we went and the lady was like,
uh,
I don't know kids.
Um,
I'm going to give you some antibiotics and,
uh,
let's hope this works.
Whoa.
Like she had never seen nothing,
nothing.
I said,
well,
will this go down?
Is it an allergy?
She's like,
could be like,
it was like,
I should've just asked my sister.
Oh,
maybe,
I don't know.
His Hitler mustache took a while too,
and then he couldn't shave.
So it looked like shape right here and it said that seriously.
So did you just grow a mustache just grow over the whole thing?
No,
he didn't want to do that.
He thought that looked crazy.
I still,
I think it's crazier to look like Hitler with a man completely ruined,
ruined the mustache for a tire forever.
That mustache can't be pulled off.
Lou.
And he took it from chaplain.
Yeah.
Chaplain shorten it though.
It's still mid,
tighter.
It's like chaplain,
like if you see one of those things,
you assume it's a Hitler.
Even if it's a Chaplin,
you can be a Charlie Chaplin Fan.
You can't wear that mustache.
It's too close to Hitler,
which is all related to my favorite website of all time cats.
It look like Hitler,
Hitler's.
Oh,
I can't every day.
Every day or really?
Yeah,
they have new ones every day.
What is wrong with you man,
and my other favorite is just the photo of the Batman Kat.
Do you know him?
I said greatest.
We're no,
if it's for sale just on the road too much.
No.
This is what I do when my brother calls and tries to explain financial things to
me,
I go on,
Huh?
Yeah,
I've had,
yeah,
I'll see.
Come on.
How is that not funny?
How do you not buy that cat?
If you see it?
It's cute cat.
Some of them,
there's one and he's got World War II gear on.
It's really funny.
It's only funny now in 2013 right.
It wouldn't have been funny in 1948 it would have been too soon.
No,
and it can't be offensive because they're cats.
They don't know.
They didn't do it on purpose.
They might have though.
What if you thought that that cat was Hitler?
Hitler.
They'd called killers.
They're called killers.
Okay.
We've seen enough.
Brian loves stupid cats.
Me Too.
I fall for it.
This is what I do when my brother calls and tells me I have to pay attention.
I go,
okay,
pat.
Yeah,
sure.
Bad.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that's fine.
Yeah.
So since uh,
last comic standing,
how much of an impact did that have on like people coming out to see you?
Uh,
well,
it got people that watch prime time.
They usually have kids and real jobs and go to bed and don't stay up and watch
Letterman and Leno.
It exposed me to new people,
but it's not like,
that's why everybody is getting way too excited when we're doing the show.
Well,
I'm going to do this,
I'm going to do this.
I'm going to tell this guy to go fuck himself now,
man.
Like thinking that this is just another step in a giant staircase.
It's not a is it,
you're not going to leap anywhere from this.
You got to build on it and everybody just needs to know what it is for now.
Who got the biggest from that show,
if you have ever imagined what,
who,
who had the biggest,
who had the biggest impact?
I would say the person that got the most out of it was Ralphie May.
He's the one he worked at and always an advantage.
Uh,
being a big fat guy,
you're recognizable liking seriously.
I get Fiko walking around an airport with John Pinette,
every single person,
all my God,
you're the buffet guy cause they saw him.
Oh Ron White.
He's huge runs.
Luke can get lost in a crowd.
I,
I'm,
I'm a dwarf.
Nobody even sees me walking in if I have a baseball hat and forget it.
But the recognizable,
and then Ralphie worked hard and worked it and I think he's still,
a lot of his people came to him through that.
I had already,
there's a lot of good people just didn't capitalize well,
they capitalize.
But I don't really know that they could have what,
you know,
what's,
I have oil and then some were just not stable.
I mean,
you know,
well how many communities are some of them out on the road alone,
right?
Oh my God.
You know,
I won't mention it.
I mean the one guy would still just be wandering around Nashville.
You know what I mean?
Like you,
you can't allow that.
You'd have to send a handler or something because they or some of them hadn't
done the road at Knopf and you just kept going wherever your career was.
That's where you're going to just keep going.
But people,
there were some people on the show.
I think that these ideas that just because we're really famous right now.
Yes,
we're very recognizable right now.
This doesn't mean it's going to last.
No,
nothing does.
Nothing lasts.
It was interesting seeing guys like Jane London,
like get this big bump and all of a sudden we were hanging out with this comedy
store and people come up to him and ask him to take pictures.
I was like,
wow.
And you know,
I told you I did my first TV show with Jay and like 92 so it was wild to see
that it was wild to see like all of a sudden things were happening
and how many people really like fell in love with Jay?
Like they were all that was their guy at his stuff is quirky and funny and
weird.
He,
I just didn't know there were that many.
I think your fans reflect your act.
I didn't understand that there were that many people as weird as Jay.
Well he's not in a bad way,
right?
No,
he's very funny.
It's just if I saw the whole show,
uh,
Jay wouldn't be the,
the one I would have written fan mail to first.
It's not say the wrong thing.
He's funny.
He is funny,
but I don't connect with him and like,
it was hard.
I tried to,
he's so sweet,
but I dunno.
Yeah.
God,
welcome back to the liquid.
This makes me don't play this.
Okay.
Yeah,
I can watch.
That's how bad it was.
Like Vietnam,
that's how bad that experience was.
It wasn't really that bad.
Yeah.
I don't usually,
I don't,
I don't being trapped in the house for a month get well just we don't own that.
They just ruined it because I thought it was going to be fun.
I love Todd glass.
I love John Half.
Ron were friends,
fun and just hanging out in the house together.
But then once you got there,
the artificial drama.
Yeah they want to take,
they took away.
We had no phones,
no Internet,
no newspaper.
Because that would date the episode.
If I'm reading the newspaper it says USA Today,
Blah Blah.
A book and a Yes,
but you had to put your on book covers on them.
So yeah,
but then you get in trouble for reading.
Come on,
we got another challenge for you guys.
And then they drive us challenge.
Yeah,
we had to go do challenges.
They were terrible and they were know what kind of challenges ill thought out.
So they owned you guys for a month?
Yeah,
we were their slaves.
You couldn't leave if you left,
you would get,
so I said,
what happens if I leave the property if I run away?
Is there like a guard tower while I get shot.
Is this like Hogan's heroes and there's somebody in,
because we were in some castle up in the Brentwood Canyon with did they use to
shoot porn?
I guess it,
they rent this place out.
It's filthy.
It was filthy to his gross.
Um,
they said,
well you'll your contract and then we'll sue you cause I really did think I'm
just going to run away.
I can't do this anymore.
I don't care enough to go through this.
If they would sue.
Did anybody leave?
Did anybody try it?
No,
but I thought you could also say medical reasons.
Yeah.
Total.
Right.
Eat something bad gets fucked.
They would bring you back cause somebody like broke their leg I think or
something and they went and fixed it and brought him back.
May Not have been a serious,
is breaking a leg but fell.
We couldn't uh,
go on the treadmill because that made too much noise for the filming.
We were so bored.
And then you try to,
me and John,
let's go hike.
We can't,
let's exercise.
You can't exercise while,
unless you can think of something to do besides the treadmill or the basketball
court.
I don't get it cause it all made the machines make too much noise.
Really?
Yup.
They're filming all the time.
24 hours.
24 hours a day.
There's a camera above my bed is ridiculous.
Crazy above your bed.
So you couldn't masturbate?
No.
Well you had to sleep.
How to sleep full clothes.
I'm not going on in America.
I'm not going on TV.
I'm not a super bottle.
This is not happening so quick.
And they,
you couldn't talk about anything.
So Tammy and I shared a room,
Pesky telly and we would write notes on the toilet paper.
I mean like prisoners.
Like I would say this is what,
this is the plan,
this is what we're going to do.
And then she would okay it and then we'd flush the toilet paper down the thing
cause they didn't have a camera.
The only place it could have a camera was in the bathroom.
That's ridiculous.
Yeah.
It's not what people,
yeah,
that's insane.
I can't even believe people agree to do that.
We didn't know.
We didn't know what they were gonna do.
Did anybody step up and say,
listen,
we know what it was.
It became like,
uh,
how I would envision you.
Um,
they call it like when you get a patty Hearst,
when you brainwash people,
it's a very slow yeah.
You,
you know,
first it's like,
here's where you're gonna live and you'd think,
oh,
okay.
Right.
You see this big castle up in the hills.
This will be fun every step of the way.
I still had hope for fun and they would just shoot the hope right out of the
barrel.
And it was just,
it was just absolutely,
it was torture.
Awful.
I didn't think you can make me not have fun with Todd glass.
How did that,
how did,
how did you manage that?
Nobody is more fun than Todd.
How many seasons they do that thing?
Uh,
I think I judged the one after that.
That was three and then four,
they stopped doing that.
The house thing around fourth thing.
Yeah.
But that's where it got weird.
He hosted it when I judged it.
Yeah.
Well,
how come you didn't keep doing it?
I don't know.
No idea.
If they would have let all the comedians have what they want.
Like you said,
let me have my wine like half rotten.
I have his beard so that the pot guys have their pot,
whatever.
And then just film us talking a conversation.
That's funny.
But no,
everything was organized and just the challenges were so degrading.
We had to go to comedy in front of five year olds.
Why is that was a challenge.
Yeah.
Uh,
and I actually won that one cause I didn't do comedy.
I just told them a story and they liked to me best.
It's all,
you know,
it's like,
well,
is a kid going to like me?
I just,
we would never do that and stand up comedy.
I would never accept,
uh,
money to perform at a five year old's birthday party.
It's like a,
it's like call the clown in Northampton.
He's available.
It's not just terrible challenges that made no sense.
They're not connected to our job.
Well,
one was like a do a,
and this was that.
It did make me laugh,
uh,
to go through what a Hollywood in one of the tour buses and be the funny tour
guide,
but these are people who actually paid so they don't really want to watch my
lame attempt at being funny about this tour.
Aunt did it for a living though before he was a comic.
Aunts was great.
I sat there and listened and I was like,
Oh man,
I go,
that was a great tour,
but I didn't know he did for a living and then he told me he made half of it up
anyway and I go,
well,
what would be the difference for a tourist if you told me that was Dolly Parton
Song?
I'd be like,
oh,
I thought that like though it doesn't really matter if it's Sally part,
it's all,
if I think I saw it,
then I saw it.
Let's you get that one wise ass and the crowd that knows that's not Dolly
Parton's home.
Right,
right.
He'd need another two blocks away.
You don't even know what you're talking about.
My Star maps as original
that where you're like,
wow,
you have totally managed to make me hate myself.
My job,
my choice for being here.
There's a way to do it though.
This is a way to do a reality show with standup comedians more.
It could be really fun.
There is definitely way it.
If somebody would go pitch it you,
they know you well enough.
Do you have power go in and every network it has 13 million people watching it
per episode in summer.
That's unheard of.
They,
when they say American idol's ratings are crap,
they've fallen to 19 I'm like,
we had 13 as comics.
American idol's ratings are crap falling every year.
They just keep falling.
Really?
This TV,
you know people are tired of it.
Everyone still have 19 million fucking people.
That's is there anyone?
Is there anybody left?
It has an audition.
Come on.
I mean it has an audit.
Oh,
hasn't all his shit growing up who've watched American idol a known that this
was their chance.
Is that breakout moment?
This is it.
That's a really good argument.
I think the judging because once you break up the initial judges,
you know,
I loved Paula.
You can't get rid of her pills out of her mind being know what was going on.
Seeing that much drinking on TV since bewitched.
I loved it.
And she literally for booze,
right.
You guys have to buy,
it's in a height Hakan Song here.
Just guards.
That's,
and that was it.
Yeah.
That's the good shit wasn't with things.
Don't know what the matter was,
but I liked it.
Whatever the matter was more of it.
And then to let her go.
I'm like,
yeah.
Uh,
if somebody hasn't done though the proper reality show with comics yet,
they haven't done it.
They haven't figured it out.
The best parts of my show or me and Dunkin hanging around in my,
the one I thought was the best part is the funnest part was just me and Dunkin
investigating Ufos,
bigfoot and shit together,
just goofing around me.
It just so happened that we were looking for bigfoot.
What was fun was hanging out with Dunkin.
Right.
Did you see the new big foot footprint today?
Does it look good bro?
I believe that new big foot print and the dead Shoup AQAP or last week.
That was interesting.
The guy who shot that,
that thing that he said was a Chupacabra in Mississippi.
A raccoon or something.
Um,
no,
I don't think they know what the fuck it is.
They think it's like a coyote with a mange.
But uh,
but it was really fresh.
The body was really fresh after each shot.
It like he was poking it.
It was still pliable.
Hooves.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
Well it has long claws.
New Chewbacca.
What are you saying?
You think it's a Chupa carver?
Is that what you're telling me?
We're gonna think it's real.
And you liked the Armadillo dare moving north.
He started,
they started in Mexico.
Chupa cobre in the news.
The trooper cover a video
camera with them.
Look good.
Chupacabra really man shot at you because it was on CNN,
right?
I saw it on Huffington Post.
Yeah.
Post huff post.
Okay.
Yeah.
There it is.
August 27th this silly bitch has a video fill this Canyon k captures Texas blue
dog possibly.
Chupacabra
yeah.
Oh,
this is another one.
I don't really count.
It kills a mysterious animal and a repurpose chicken coop this morning.
And some people in the area say it could be the mythical to macabre have a
hairless creature was killed in a pig town.
[inaudible] Mississippi,
new Shovel Coal Jacob kiddle set takes us there.
But first,
if you're just a little squeamish,
you may want to look away if the story contains some graphic images.
Hmm.
Suffering.
It's like attack
armed with his 22 Matt Hugh Harrell was coon hunting when he saw the red eyes
and the,
hey,
this wasn't,
I mean he wouldn't have,
hey,
we're das hold like a cat.
And unlike a typical coyote,
the beast moved to attack.
Oh,
when I was standing right,
John Right here.
We were like,
he was sending jumped down there and I didn't even change.
He brought her down here and showed a 10 man,
which my labor,
when he a child got chicken houses and uh,
he said he's seen it.
Don't walk two or three times in the city.
Wrong.
Funny is funny and we're lower than this.
Back in.
I said it was one them cool combos or whatever and
I'll [inaudible] July here.
It's still alive.
She is almost without hair.
Nails longer than a dog's on its paws and a build online,
not one animal.
A local scene in the area.
Oh,
oh,
oh my dog.
Even one a day and then my dog was scared of it.
Chupacabra Spanish work literally translated as suck goat for the mythic
creature.
Attacks,
livestock draining blood by chomping down on to farm animals flesh.
Wow.
That's some good watermelon.
Anyway,
it's the Department of Wildlife and fisheries says that this to Pecan
right
play more likely a wild dog or coyote with mange,
but the locals are not having any of it.
I don't really know why.
Okay.
I mean you look at it,
I never signed the Blue Code.
Matt says he dismissed the mains explanation.
The moment he shouted
and I'll read on my gun and I walked over my shine a light down our oh shit,
my God.
I said,
well,
and I unload it again or make sure you will.
And based on the late of the Hay in the barn,
another rumor has also started going around,
well,
it's weird to me and I figured out for more
you answers in Lee County back to you.
Well,
what's interesting is that thing looks exactly like these other ones that
they've shot.
Yeah,
yeah.
There's more,
I mean there's more than one that look like really similar,
almost exactly the same.
And the deck,
I looks exactly like Dale Earnhardt Jr so probably is real.
Yeah,
right.
He's real and so is that it was a fucking real animal or coyote type animal that
they just hadn't discovered yet.
There's the trooper Cabo really was real.
Did he's a mix between uh,
uh,
Mexican wolf and then some sort of coyote.
Well,
what's interesting is they found a really recently in America,
they found Jaguars that have made it up from South America.
They're starting to find here in Phoenix,
they're finding out I'm on camera traps.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
We'll here.
I'll pull up.
So you could say,
I'll pull up some pictures.
Jaguar in Phoenix
or in Arizona.
What's the difference for Jaguar and a Puma?
Puma is a cougars.
Mountain Lion.
A Jaguar is a much larger animal.
A little looser.
Okay.
A little more dangerous.
A Jaguar is more dangerous than a lion.
No more or less dangerous than a mountain lion.
Yeah.
See there,
they're spotted.
They were crazy.
The catching,
they're finding these in Arizona.
Oh,
shut up.
You could see it.
Wow.
Yeah.
That's a camera trap.
Photo in Arizona with a fucking giant South American cat.
Well,
that's,
you know,
the whole,
do you know they're black too?
Sometimes.
This is one that's in northern Mexico.
Look at that.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
They found that close to the United States border and they've,
uh,
there's been some of Jaguars Black Jaguars in America.
They haven't been substantiated.
They don't know whether or not they're out.
They actually legit.
Uh,
Jamie.
Um,
but they,
uh,
they know they're making it up here.
There's a lot of photographs of them in Arizona.
Oh look,
here's another one.
Oh my God.
They're fucking huge.
Yeah.
They were like way bigger than a mountain line.
Uh,
you know,
I,
I was teasing Lou,
we did this big golf thing,
charity thing,
and in Phoenix I said,
we're staying at this place where the CASITA's are way out in the middle.
You follow these paths?
I go,
careful,
careful of the hub.
Aleena's and he said,
what is that?
And I said,
they're tiny pigs at a tag you in the night.
He was like,
you're totally making that up.
I said,
no,
I'm not Google it beat people think I'm making it up.
I'm not
the New Mexico to Jaguars in New Mexico.
They say they're using the same routes that the drug dealers use.
Probably.
Yeah.
Well that's what they're saying.
They're saying you shouldn't clan to the same clan to Stein routes as drug
smugglers.
Male Jaguars are crossing into the United States from Mexico
illegally.
No paperwork.
Exactly.
And they're fuck.
So wait,
that thing is bigger than a lion mountain lion.
Bigger than a mountain.
It's bigger than a mountain lion.
Yes.
Wow.
Yeah.
Let's say Jaguar.
There's not a thing.
There are about 200 pounds.
Hot.
See the cat not the car.
You fuck heads.
Wikipedia wants me to send me to Jaguar USA.
What's the average weight?
That's a big cat.
I didn't find anything because you're a dumb cunt.
Siri.
Siri,
you useless.
Oh,
asked the Google Person My,
I betcha they know more.
Yeah.
Let's see.
I don't remember how to do it.
What's the average weight of a Jaguar?
350 pounds.
They can weigh as much as 350 pounds,
larger
mail.
It's just did it gave me an answer right there.
Yeah.
I don't have the sound on or you could have heard it.
Weights are normally in the range of 90 56 to 96 kilograms,
which is 124 to 211 pounds.
Larger males had been recorded to weigh as much as 350 pounds or 160 kilograms
roughly matching a Tigris or Elias.
So the males grow to the same size as a female lion.
That's how big male Jaguars are.
That's a big fucking cat.
Yeah.
Because my brother's afraid to go hunting in Missouri because he's secretly
afraid of mountain lions.
But he won't tell my dad,
Dad,
cause my dad would make fun of them.
So when you're going out in the morning,
it's dark in the woods.
There are trail cams in Missouri with pictures of,
they're all about 200 pounds.
So yeah,
Mountain Lion,
Missouri.
Yeah,
I saw one in Santa Barbara,
some mountain line in Monosito.
Shut up man.
Driving down the street wasn't a big one.
It was probably about 80 70 80 pounds.
But I saw bounding across the street.
It was fucking loud,
like dark out.
And I thought it was a coyote for a second.
And then I saw its tail,
Mike,
that's a cat tail and I'm like,
oh my God,
it's a mountain lion running across the street real quick.
I went golfing with my dad in Florida and if my mom,
my mom's afraid of dogs,
my mom's afraid of everything.
But I went with him and we were on a whole,
it was a golf course like in a queue.
So it's well developed community,
like a subdivision.
And I said,
what is that?
And I saw this thing coming towards the tee box and it was sauntering like,
and he's like,
that saw Bob Mountain Lion.
And I said,
I at that sure is and we need to get in the cart and get the fuck outta here.
But it just,
it walked as if it was just going to play the hall and then it kept walking and
I was like,
wow.
Well apparently in the swamps now down there,
the panthers are out of control in Florida,
completely out of hand,
real along with the pythons,
the pythons in the pants.
There's,
because every,
I don't know how the panther thing started,
but the python from the people dumping their pets that they couldn't end up
taking care of and now they're allowing people to go on python haunts.
I'm like,
I don't really think,
if you don't know how to do that,
you should do that.
They should do that.
Let him,
let him,
let him like weed them out.
So many fucking people.
Anyway,
I let him go,
well,
we're Finna go pass on hunting.
There's they,
they're having a real hard time with that though.
They can't find them.
They're having a really hard,
I know.
So they were sending the idiots out and they are finding them.
It's the same like those two guys.
Did you see the alligator,
the largest one ever?
Just like dice.
We'd call it by those two guys.
Well,
large one in Mississippi.
Yeah.
More.
Well,
in two in one day they broke their same record.
They're broke the world record in will the state record in Mississippi and one
day it was like 600 something pounds and then two people on the same day caught
more than 700 pounders.
Wow.
They're so big to carry guys.
I was in South Carolina,
queue up golf in with Lou and there there's alligators everywhere.
I go,
but who eats the alligator?
Who kills you?
Alligator.
He goes,
other alligators.
I said,
no way.
They're cannibals.
He goes,
oh yeah.
they dominate a pond like on a golf course in the swampy golf courses that they,
they dominate a pond.
And then if anyone knew alligators come to their pond,
they just eat them.
So who's their natural predator?
Except did you see the video of that mount line taken out and the alligator or
not?
Or what are the common South America?
Not An alligator I can be in.
Or a Cayman.
Cayman.
Yeah.
Uh,
that it's a Jaguar.
It's not a video.
It's pictures and you see him.
That's a Jaguar.
Okay.
One of the animals is getting into it doesn't have spots though.
They don't always have spa.
Okay.
Black ones too.
Okay,
well that thing took down an alligator and they go,
finally,
here's a predator.
Because who's their predator?
Why aren't there millions and millions in first?
That's a small crocodile to those Caymans.
Yeah,
it's Jaguar eating and Cayman car.
These are actually a couple of youtube videos.
One control that,
if he can pull that up,
that is,
yeah,
they're fucking ferocious cats.
Yeah.
And this is what
I hear
key.
Oh Wow.
Fuck these animals,
man.
Eight spectacular looking though.
It is.
I mean,
I wouldn't want to see it,
but look at that fucking creepy thing.
If I was standing,
he blends right in so well.
Of course.
He's a tall,
let's go baby crocodile by the head,
dragging it out of the water.
Wow.
Yeah.
They eat them.
I mean,
that's how bad as they are.
They eat crocodiles now.
Tough fucking crocodile skin is.
These fuckers just chew right through it.
Wow.
Yeah.
That is a big fucking cat,
man.
That's a really big fucking cat.
Well,
and they say they'll stalk us.
Oh,
fuck you people.
The only reason why they don't is because they don't do it all the time that
they did it all the time.
If you're used to killing people,
they would.
That would be on the menu.
They're not ethical.
Like people have this ridiculous idea that while they don't even eat people,
they don't just don't know about it yet.
It's a delicacy they've heard of.
They just love it.
It's that everyday menu add becomes a huge problem in any area where they do
have that already go down.
That's already went down.
Once you show the attack part,
it becomes a real problem in any area where big cats find out that they can eat
people.
That's what that movie,
that ghost in the darkness was about.
These lions got a taste of,
oh shit,
whoa.
Look how fast this mother fucker moves.
Wow.
Okay.
They only have it in slow motion or they show it in full speed.
Is this full be no,
the run running their only show him awesome.
It's too bad
when you see them move,
like pounce on something.
You see how quick that they can cover distance.
There's one,
um,
look up.
This Jaguar eats copy Barra,
Jaguar kills copy Barra.
What's a copy of Bobby bar is a giant rodent,
a huge road and like a hundred pound rodent that lives in the Amazon and Jaguars
eat them and they stock them when these people catch them all the time because
the coffee bar,
a feed like right on the shore and the Jaguar sneak through the grass right on
the shore and it happens on film all the time.
Whether they just come bum rush these giant rats,
it's a fuck them up.
Look at this.
Look how creepy that motherfucker has to be moving.
Those are so terrifying.
Look how creepy he is.
And then he'd just sprints
and there's a cabinet bar.
Yup.
Look at that role like gator roll.
He just did my hold it on that things neck.
Okay.
He's got it by the face,
man.
He doesn't even have him by the neck.
He hasn't by his face.
Just dragging them into the woods where he fucks him up.
There's a few videos like this.
That's this a pretty good one.
But there's a gang of these videos.
It happens all the time.
There's a,
there's a great one.
Where gets it in the water?
Yeah.
Is Coffee Bar.
They have those things at the Santa Monica.
Is the or the San Diego Zoo?
Uh,
no.
Yeah,
I think so.
Well,
no,
I'm Santa Barbara there.
About which ones though?
The coffee bars,
they have those things.
They're like the same as a nutria.
Yeah,
no bigger way bigger.
Oh yeah.
Look at this.
This one doesn't even know that fucking things.
They're looking at just wandering around like a dumb ass dude tutor to do a
giant rent.
What's that thing right there?
Just pick,
pick,
pick.
Oh my God.
At these people in the,
yeah.
Those people are right there.
Oh well.
Like Holy Shit.
He just ran into the water to gang them.
I'm looking at him.
He's way out there with a rat in his mouth,
a giant rat,
and he's going to swim to shore and I would not be standing.
Well,
it's just such a weird thing that things willing to go into the water and kill.
Why isn't it going get you?
Yeah.
Right.
Look at this and it just kills it right in front of these fucking people.
It doesn't give a flying fuck that there's two boats there with cameras and guns
and shit.
Does that black,
is that a black one?
Yeah,
it's a dark,
dark one at least.
And they vary.
Yeah,
it's mighty too,
I'm sure.
But they vary sometimes their spots,
so like almost their whole bodies a spot.
And you can see like in the really black Jaguars,
you can see the kind of uh,
the little,
the coloration,
but they come on,
they vary.
Some of them are completely black and those are the ones that are the fucking
scariest.
The hunt at night.
Right.
You can't see anything when you're in the jungle.
In the Amazon.
Apparently it's the most terrifying thing because they're everywhere and they're
just looking for something to kill at night and they can see.
They could see like the fucking fluorescence or on.
That's why do you watch at show naked and afraid?
Yes.
Love it.
It's great.
What's your favorite survival rating?
Give you a primitive survival.
Ready Watch.
I told my brother minds negative for,
I would start crying the minute the helicopter was landing and kicking me out.
That's last comic standing taken to the next level.
It will,
yeah.
It is basically the same thing or until we kill each other.
You either die on your own or I kill you,
kill you.
It's basically the same thing,
but they put them in horrible places and I know,
you know my brother goes,
well they producers and stuff,
Kathleen.
Yeah,
I know,
but a producer can't stop a spider.
Yeah,
or a wolf.
You right?
Yeah.
If you're naked,
you know how much it would suck if you got bit by a wolf and you were naked.
Oh my God.
What?
Take it with Wolf.
Just grabs your belly,
just locks on your belly and starts chewing through it.
Just raw meat right there.
It would visit.
Erupt were made out of butter.
We're basically made out of butter.
We just slice wide open.
Yeah,
we'd be easy like a little seal for him.
Just a little seals.
Way tougher than their skin is tougher.
You're right.
Wait,
you can make shoes out of them.
Seal shoes I'm sure can make that course I did.
Okay.
Let's see.
Leather.
Let's say no.
Can you make leather out of seals?
I bet you can.
Wet seal leather jacket.
That wet seal is snow.
Snow seal original bees.
Whack waterproofing.
I'm Australian leather seal seal leather.
Can you make leather out of seals?
No.
Actually you can.
Wow.
That's weird.
Huh?
Leather made from seals.
Let's try that.
This might be bullshit.
Look at Ios seven somebody posted a photo.
Joe Is this Siri,
what's the average weight of a Jaguar?
Look how the answers now like the answer and it gives you all this shit like
conversions and,
but it's off by a hundred pounds.
Siri.
Stupid bitch can make leather out of seal biggest ones.
Hmm.
It doesn't say why don't mean from seals.
Yeah.
Show me a picture of seals face.
There's all this other seal leather.
There's like leather seals.
The problem is it's like stuffy put on leather to seal it.
They call it leather seal.
So when you Google it,
that's mostly what you find.
Yes.
Made from a seal.
Ken Seals be made into leather.
That's a good one.
Oh,
it's all back to the Aragon.
How to make a leather piss deals.
Facts
seal skins.
Yes.
Can Melt leather seal down to a liquid form.
No,
that's not the right answer.
But light and wind con.
Yeah,
it,
you can use a seal.
Skin seal skin is something they use.
Let's say do the Inuits who Easterseal porn.
Um,
can,
can Canada exports the following seal product,
seal skins first skins pelts and leather seal oil and seal meat stasis.
This is a all about seal hunting.
It's,
I'm a conservation website that's trying to save seals because they fucking
club.
I'm the guy to death.
Right?
We're really their oil particular moment.
Watch that show.
'Em.
What's that crazy one where they,
oh,
a above the arctic circle.
Yeah.
It's on Nat Geo to the seal oil is what they used for cooking and everything.
Seal oil.
Yes.
It's very valuable.
Yeah.
They use it for like lamps too,
right?
Yup.
Yeah.
Well that's the other set of crazy people that people on that show.
Seal meat.
They sell seal meat.
They sell a lot of different things.
Wow.
That's so weird.
Finding out here's the Canada not satisfied the underperformance of seal meat
sales according to their own website.
Finding a market for seal meat outside of Newfoundland continues to present a
major challenge for the ceiling industry.
The amount of seal meat landed in 2002 was extremely low in part because the
hunt was mainly directed at younger animals,
which have very little recoverable meet beaters.
They call them beaters.
Oh my God.
That's the ones they beat to death because they want their fur because the
younger ones are white and fluffy before they get old and funky
beating baby cook club clubbing baby seals.
That's like what our Busmat about
and they sell seal oil capsules.
They sell it as a nutritional supplement?
Yeah.
Wow.
I think you live,
if you live above the Arctic Circle,
you can do whatever you want.
Yeah.
You,
you're living in the gangster world.
You have to fit right in.
Yup.
If you need to go,
um,
club a seal,
then I don't think you need,
do you ever watch those shows like Alaska,
the great front,
the last frontier.
I haven't watched that one that I liked.
The one of where they live,
they have like six people that they focus on that live above the arctic circle.
Right.
That's the one lady in our own camp.
I can't think of her name.
It's like the,
you want to,
she has like a little sayings and stuff.
Were you like,
this is the hardest woman I've ever seen.
Ever.
You want to,
you want to be of a pork chop it,
you're going to,
you got to act like a pork chop.
Like things like she's always,
she's always haunting the wolves and other things around her camp.
That's like miles and I,
you can't,
I can't even when I really can't believe this.
There's a crew up there.
Yeah.
Where are they staying and somebody,
they have to go film this stuff every day.
There's a family that lives in an Igloo.
I mean,
okay.
Best one is mountain men.
You ever watch that one?
I haven't.
It's on the history channel and it's about these guys and one of them,
this guy,
Marty Mirano,
he lives in the dark north of Alaska.
He lives deep into the woods.
He has to fly on a fucking plane,
two hours over like woods to land in the camp where he goes like for for two
hours he's flying around not seeing nothing but trees.
There's no cities,
no nothing.
I'm afraid of bears.
He's got to be afraid of bears.
Got to carry a rifle every time.
He does take a shit.
Everything he does,
he has to have a rifle on him.
That's why.
Okay.
I love house hunters.
I know it's a chick show.
Just let,
they were looking at Alaska.
These people wanted to get away.
They want it as far away from possible or no,
it's not.
It wasn't how centers,
it's a show buying Alaska.
Yeah.
And so,
uh,
they were like,
well,
we want to,
but they're like from Wisconsin.
Right.
And that people were like,
you don't seem to understand what's going to happen because they're up there in
summertime.
Right.
Uh,
first of all,
I said,
what if you have to go to the bathroom in the middle of the night?
You have to take a gun because there was a bear.
Yes.
Who wants it?
Who would choose to,
to,
what is the perk?
What is the park?
The perks seems to be with all these people.
We don't want to be around any other people.
When you're taking it that far at they,
there's something wrong.
What's really wrong?
Well,
some people,
they love the idea of living with nature too.
It's not just about being with no people.
It's like every day you're going to see a moose or you're going to see a bear.
You're going to see there's something really magical about that.
I don't want to live like that,
but I get it.
I get that part,
but
when the,
the living becomes so difficult,
it would take the joy out of the Moose for me when it's going to take us 11
hours in a sled to go get some smokes.
There's no smokes up there.
You roll your own tobacco and we got to get paper.
We need,
AH,
some bread.
We need some diet coke.
I mean at all of a sudden living,
they need some diet coke.
We need that.
That you say when you're living in Alaska,
roughing it in a house made out of trees.
Well,
okay beer.
I don't know what people need to live,
but what do you want it to store?
It's going to take us 11 hours a slide.
Well this guy,
Marty,
he,
he's a trapper and he lives like in,
it's like 50 below zero all the time where he lives.
His beard gets entirely covered with ice and snow is the gnarliest shit you've
ever seen.
The guy's walking around in his face is just covered in this room.
White snow,
frozen beard.
And he's up there wandering around alone.
Yeah,
he lives alone.
This is not,
what were you looking at?
What are you doing?
You were talking about like [inaudible] no,
no,
no.
But you like,
you know who you answer?
The fucking fake guy.
He's like,
Les Stroud hates.
Yeah,
he's eating a full meal out there pretending to be roughing it.
Yeah.
It's that guy selling that stock show was created because of survivor man.
You know,
Les Stroud,
like they wanted less job to do all this fake shit.
Like,
let's pretend you just shot a moose and we'll bring in a moose.
And was like,
no,
like I'm not doing,
I'm not faking anything.
And they wanted to fake a bunch of things and they were like,
look,
we know how to make television.
He's like,
I'm not faking it.
So they made that show and put it on the same network just to fuck him.
Just to like,
wow.
Yeah,
but that show is bullshit.
Like that guy doesn't he?
The guy stays in hotels every night,
which is not really the guy on the far left.
Bear Grylls.
No.
But what show is this?
Uh,
what is his show?
I forget what it's called,
but when people found out that he was bullshitting everybody,
like they've stopped watching it,
man versus mammary for
wild.
Yeah.
Oh,
that's where they drop them off.
Okay.
Yeah,
I've seen it.
It didn't seem real.
No,
not doing a very good job of shaking it.
It was,
it was really obviously fake.
It wasn't just like a little bit of fake.
It was,
I mean the guy would like do all this crazy shit that you would never do like g
leap from the top of an ice cliff and slide down this ice tunnel.
Like like why would you,
why are you doing all this?
Like you're doing a stunt in the movie.
That's not what you would do if you were surviving.
If you're out here,
Ryan,
you wouldn't be having fun.
You're surviving,
surviving.
It's not,
there's no games
currently.
They edit them.
Removing elements that were two planned.
They had to,
they re edited some of the episodes with a fresh voiceover and a proceeding
announcement pointing out that some situations are in quotes presented to bear
to show the viewer how to survive.
However,
five of the most controversial season one episodes were never released,
never re released after editing and are no longer available on DVD,
flowery.
These are the Rockies,
the mob desert,
Costa Rican,
rain forest,
mount,
mount key,
Luhya,
a Hawaii and a desert island in Hawaii.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
I'm still just shut out.
The discovery channel really took a hit in my world because of Megla done.
Mcglynn Darren.
I believed it.
Oh,
they lied about like the whale that washed up on shore was missing half.
It's
[inaudible].
They made up all of it.
How about the fucking mermaids?
What's not animal planet?
They made up mermaids.
That was discovery as well.
Was it?
I'm almost positive.
Come on.
Look it up.
Okay.
Discovery Channel.
No.
Your mind or it might've been animal planet.
It was the biggest show ever on animal planet.
People are so fucking stupid.
They're like mom telling you,
Ma,
there's a fucking mermaid.
That one I didn't believe,
but I did believe mega della Don was possible.
You did believe?
Yeah,
I saw the shark that got bitten in half.
Yeah.
You have a discovery channel?
Mermaids.
Okay.
What's,
Oh,
it's animal planet.
I guess animal planet.
Part discovery or together.
Yeah.
Here's what's Ma,
what's wrong with this?
So like animal planet is supposed to be educating kids to write,
which is dark.
Wasn't the show won one of those.
What ifs shows?
It's animals.discovery.com.
That's the website.
That's interesting.
So animal planet is owned by discovery and it's the animal planet website were
surprisingly human animal planet.
It wasn't,
what if it wasn't?
Oh No.
They had a guy from the navy.
Oh,
it was totally fake.
They had an animation and they had like a fake mermaid.
It's really disgusting.
What they did.
Everybody,
a real investigation documentary with real people.
Um,
my friend Lorraine,
no,
her husband Tony is a scientist.
He goes,
I dunno why yelling?
You would have believed any of this.
It could just know scientists aren't that hot ever.
The other thing is why they're showing it on TV and it's channeled.
It doesn't show fiction.
It's a,
it's an educational channel.
It's supposed to be.
So it was so,
it's discovery.
I cannot believe they would.
They talk an hour on my life.
I'm not only did I believe it,
I texted my brother and said,
you have got to go to evo or whatever.
Record Megla.
Dot.
Yeah.
All fake.
They're just out of their fucking mind.
I can't believe they even put this on the air,
but it just goes to show you when you were talking about like how hard it is to
make a good show because you're dealing with producers,
you're dealing with networks.
He did with all these fucking crazy people.
If they can let an idea get like this,
go through like they like,
yeah,
that's for Thomas Rail.
I just fucking pretentious room.
It
tended,
they found mermaids.
You're an asshole.
You are a fucking asshole.
You made a fake mermaid show on a discovery,
you know,
and that's something you would sit down and watch with your kids and they would
go to moon or going over to metal one.
I really get me cause,
and you got to explain it to your kids that the people on television are liars,
sheds heads.
We had an issue on my show where,
um,
there was,
uh,
we had a reedit one of the episodes because the first airing it was the,
um,
uh,
weaponized whether episode,
I saw it,
the first airing they showed this thing,
which is called a sky quake and they said,
sent in from a podcast viewer.
So I,
I have zero to do with the editing.
I could say that I don't like this or we got to take this out,
but I didn't see this.
They just,
they stuck this in because we did like six episodes and we did them all in a few
months.
It was a really quick,
and it was like within,
they brought,
I brought them the idea,
they said yes.
And then we started filming like almost immediately.
Wow.
And it was crazy and we banged out six episodes and made a lot of mistakes.
But one of the big ones is one of the editors lied and they put this video
footage and,
and put this fake noise behind it and set a podcast listener sent in this sound
of a sky.
Quigg well,
here's the problem.
The guy whose video that they used when they faked it was a guy who is being
criticized on the show.
So the guy criticized in the show was like,
no,
not only is that fake,
like that's my fucking hand,
that's my yard.
Like that's not true.
That's not real.
So I called them up and read them the riot act.
I'm like,
what the fuck?
You know what happened?
And it was,
you know,
someone edit it.
Apparently that's what they do.
Like editors,
like they create fake shit like reality in quotes shows all the time.
Right.
So they took it out of the,
the subsequent performances,
but the first air,
the episode,
first time in their first couple of times a year,
they had this lie in it,
you know,
and it's supposed to be a show about finding the truth.
And you know,
there were,
they were really upset.
Like the production company was really upset that it happened.
They didn't know it was happening.
But this is a normal way that people create these shows.
They just fucking fake it up.
This guy sent us to today,
here's a man living in Alaska.
Was stranded in the wolf,
the wolf pack,
Dan,
for six weeks,
and this is the video he sent us a bunch of wool snapping at the door.
There's no real wolves there,
man.
As you made this up,
they do it all the time.
They call it reality show and that's what Les Stroud was not willing to do.
That's why they made the bear man vs wild,
right,
because they look,
yeah,
we'll show you how smart you are and look what happened.
They got fucked because they're,
they think they're smarter than people.
They think that people are going to be too stupid to know that they're just
engineering the show and completely fabricating all this Survivorman is awesome
because that guy is a legit bad motherfucker who will go out into the woods with
a tin can and a shoe lace and survive for a week.
Right.
That's why.
What about that River Guy?
I hope that's real.
Oh,
big river man.
The guy who swam the Amazon?
No,
no.
Oh really?
Somebody.
Oh yeah.
No,
no,
a swamp.
Swampy.
Although river hunter,
the Monster Vermont.
Oh,
that guy is real.
I believe that.
That's real.
He seems to intuit to for it to be fake and he doesn't look,
uh,
right.
Like via TV host.
Like I liked the way he looks,
but he's not all
river monsters.
Yeah.
That's the guy.
Yeah,
he's awesome.
He's going fishing.
He's basically fishing for evil fish.
Right.
That's what he does.
And he's finding
them.
Yeah.
Older out there things.
Those ones that he found in Africa and the Congo,
those giant tigerfish tigerfish yourself with,
with the crazy teeth.
What the fuck?
That is some ancient shit.
That's a,
that's some dinosaur type shit.
Well,
that's why we're the one that locals explain it and then people go,
well that doesn't exist.
That's a myth.
Well,
where did a myth start?
Somebody saw something fucked up.
Yeah.
And went back to their people and said,
I just saw it out of the lake,
this river,
this fucked up thing and had teeth and it growled.
Look a tiger.
Well,
no you didn't.
Yeah,
I did.
And it was a fish.
Yeah.
When did,
when they found fire tiger fish.
That's why I liked that he talks to the locals.
Yeah.
He gets down with those fucking people.
There was something weird in Siberia to,
that's one of the first of the car.
That's the target fish.
Yeah.
Jesus fucking Christ.
Pull that shit up.
Look at that.
Pull that picture up.
That's,
so,
that was always my thing with the giant squid.
When they would say,
oh well you know,
probably not.
Probably not until the,
they've actually just recently found one,
but do you see those sketches of Japanese fishermen and the octopus is taking
them off the boat?
Who would sit down and draw that if it wasn't fucking true?
Why would you go through the bullshit of,
I'm going to sketch out this giant sea monster.
Oh Man.
So get that fucking things mouth.
Oh my God.
Well the giant squid.
The one of the things about the giant squid,
it's really fascinating is each one of those suction cups has a hook in it.
They have like a,
like it's sucks down and there's like a hook,
like a beak.
Tyco pluck you out of a rip you apart.
They would,
it would tear you apart if one of those giant squids got ahold of your body
would literally just slice you open.
Like,
like a giant rope covered in razor blades is pulled across.
Your body would just rip you to shreds.
Yeah.
There's not like just suction cups.
They have like a tooth in though.
Oh,
I thought it was a mouth wrap around deal and the Yang side of the boat.
No.
Well the,
there's that too.
But the suction cups of a giant squid have teeth.
Yeah.
It's nasty.
It's like this beak like thing here.
I'll pull it up.
Yeah.
There's so the,
the,
the fucking ocean is so God damn terrified.
It's creepy.
They found some new thing.
This video that they took.
Uh,
yeah.
Here look.
You could see that.
See the each hook.
Oh yeah.
Each one of those suction cups has hooks in it.
Like that's a God damn cat claw.
Look at that and saying,
yeah,
it's huge.
What is the new thing?
Well,
creepy news.
It's a giant jellyfish like thing that they found,
uh,
on a,
a deep sea oil rig.
Camera Brion pull up massive unidentified sea monster caught on oil rig cam and
this thing is really fucking weird and apparently it's been identified as a type
of jellyfish.
It's you see its underside,
it has like these like this weird testy area where there,
what's balls are,
it's so fucking freaky.
It looks like like a giant flying carpet monster
and it's just underneath the ocean.
I mean they find these things will always believe in the lochness monster.
Don't believe in that one.
Why?
Because the people that,
the best photographs of it are bullshit.
The best photograph they ever had was a total hoax.
The guy made up the best photograph that was ever taken.
I thought he said he did and I took that back.
The Patterson film,
that's the Patterson film.
Did he say I made it up and then he didn't,
he never said he,
but he died young.
The guy who said that he wasn't in it but then said he was,
was the,
the guy who actually wore the suit himself and he did and he's not only did he
most likely wear that suit,
he walked like it.
Look at it.
Watch this thing.
This thing swims by.
See the oil cam,
they catch it swimming.
Look at that.
It's fucking enormous.
But wait til it comes around.
Don't worry,
you can't see it yet.
Don't try to change the contrast when it comes back around and you can actually
see it again,
but it gets like right in front of the camera and you know there's oil rigs are
these huge fucking things and they have these remote cameras and they catch
these insane deep sea animals.
Like they caught this one squid that has these crab like arms,
but this thing,
it comes close.
It gets like way up to the camera.
And then why don't they think this is just like a big jellyfish or something is
it is a type of jellyfish.
That's what they had to identify and figure out what it is.
But you know,
you're talking about something that's just fucking enormous toxic waste
jellyfish.
Oh yeah.
It's probably absorbing all that Fukushima's shit.
Look at the size of that thing.
It's so weird looking to,
when it gets up to the camera,
it looks like paper.
That'd be fun to play inside of that.
If you wouldn't get hurt.
So many toxic jellyfish.
So many jellyfish will fuck you up.
That's how they protect themselves from predation.
You know,
they're just covered in stingers.
People get scarred up really bad too.
Yeah.
My friend just got bit in the backer head and by jellyfish,
huge marks on it.
It looks like she has a tattoo now on the back of her neck.
Wow.
Yeah.
Jellyfishes fuck him up,
man.
No,
that was in uh,
Italy or somewhere.
If somebody tweeted me the actual explanation and our,
I retweeted it,
so give me a second here and I'll find it.
Whatever.
This was NPR.
Npr had the answer for what it is that it's some type of a jellyfish,
but how do they know if they didn't catch it?
Because they see it and they can recognize it.
They know what it is,
but there's still a lot of shit in the ocean that they really don't know.
Yeah.
There's,
there's sounds,
biological sounds that had been recorded that are like many,
many times louder than anything a whale can make.
Right.
And they don't know.
They don't know what it is,
but they know it's a biological sound.
I think they call it the bloop.
Yeah.
Does dairy maids,
they said it was mermaids talking.
Yeah.
All those fucking dickheads.
They'll whoever put that thing on TV should go to jail.
I seriously,
it's on an educational channel.
I don't care if this is on the goofy movie channel.
There's a giant squid in real life.
Pull up giant squid with crab arms,
oil rig camera,
giant squid,
crab arms.
Cause this is the weirdest fucking thing ever.
They found this squid that has like these like crazy crab arms and it's living
underneath the water just floating around like an alien.
That's why I always,
when you see those underwater oil rig welder guys,
ah,
all my God.
Well I,
what do you make?
It's not enough how much,
how much to go down there and uh,
weld.
Look at this thing.
I mean,
tell me that doesn't look like something right out of Star Trek.
Look how long it's legs are like,
look at those fucking 10 of goals.
It looks like an alien.
They look at those things.
Yeah,
right.
Yeah.
Well,
not Asher,
but,
uh,
Geiger,
HR.
Giger.
Yeah.
Jesus Christ.
I mean,
we don't know,
literally 99%
of the Scotia I used to surf and then I also saw shark and that was the end.
Yeah.
But the other stuff that you see,
like what,
um,
the weird,
the weird jellyfish that it don't even make sense just there up on top,
floating around.
But then you'd see like a dolphin and that's really cool to be on your surfboard
and there's a dolphin right there and they're totally friendly.
You know,
they'll,
they'll not hurt you.
Um,
and to just see one in the wild and they'll surf a wave with you.
But the amount of coolness is not okay considering how many bad things are
there.
Yeah.
There's just so many unknowns.
It's Er.
Well,
and think that's why I really do think surfers are real surfers.
I mean,
it is like me that did a weekend,
but they're the bravest people.
What don't,
what other sport would you agree that the playing underneath the playing field
are the most dangerous things on earth?
That it any moment can come up and eat you like you wouldn't go on a soccer
field where they said,
we have 11 lions underneath the field and at any moment the lions can be
released and eat you.
Well,
we were in Hawaii the week that two people got bitten by sharks.
One person recently,
just this week or this month,
rather,
one person died and another person got his leg fucked up.
One guy in the big island got bit and then a woman while we were there died.
She got her arm ripped off by a shark.
Oh,
a German lady or something.
I read about it.
Yeah.
Meanwhile,
we were in the water.
We were in that same water and I was,
we were joking around.
I was like,
imagine if we were at a picnic and a werewolf came in and rip someone's chest
open and then ran back into the woods.
We'd be like,
well look,
there's not that many werewolves and this is where they live.
It's their habitat,
which is just keep playing.
Yeah.
We're going to take all with the party or in the edge of the woods with sticks.
We would have like sentience,
you know,
we would have like people out there making sure that they stood guard and
watched certain areas.
Well,
I don't understand.
Like in Australia they do have a big net at a the one beach Bondai beach.
There's a giant net sweep sharks out.
Yeah,
but it,
that people are anti net
people are anti net.
They're ass holes.
But it's an asshole.
Keep out the sea snakes.
You know how many snakes in the ocean can kill you?
I didn't even know lots of Google.
If you go well,
how many poisonous snakes in the ocean?
I'll ask my Google.
Doesn't everything in Australia kill you though?
Australia is like one of the most dangerous place.
Most poisonous snakes,
uh,
on land too,
in the whole world.
Well,
you can't even live in the middle,
right?
Australia,
like you live around the edges and you get inside the middle and you're fucked.
The middle's even worse.
Um,
my friend live with my friend lives in the middle.
That will be scared.
How many come on out to the meadow or in the ocean?
What does it say?
Oh,
it's in our stand.
Horny.
Hmm.
That's weird.
How many poisonous snakes are in the ocean?
Dupage is useless.
She's doing that to get yourself a fucking regular iPhone vet.
A venomous snake.
Sea snakes.
Um,
lots.
Okay.
I mean,
so the net.
Okay,
so you got kept the sharks out.
That's great.
But what about everything else?
There was one in my pants.
A long snake.
Hmm.
Um,
most venomous see snakes,
western Pacific Atlantic or the Atlantic.
The Caribbean and the Red Sea.
You have no seats.
Snakes.
It's even dead specimens found the beach should not be touched because some
species are known to feign death when stranded by the tide and once dead,
even decapitated snakes can still administer a reflex bite.
Oh,
okay.
Did you see the copperhead bite its own body?
Yeah,
actually said it was cut off.
You know,
my dad used to tell us that when we were kids and we didn't believe him.
Yeah.
Snakes.
Apparently the,
their head can work for
long,
long time.
Like a day to a say sundown to sundown to Sunup to sundown,
just whatever.
It just decides to clamp down on you and inject you with poison.
They just try to make sure for sure that you don't get out of this.
They want to get you,
they have like a bunch of different fail safes set up so they can get you with
that.
What's going on here,
Shelley phase.
Like I said,
my friend has one that looks like a tattoo.
This is exactly like what hers,
it looks like.
It almost looks like somebody tutor or something like that.
Ryan.
That's insane.
That's all from a jellyfish.
Correct.
The one above it.
Go back to that one above it.
Holy Fuck.
Yeah.
And it lasts for like a long time.
Like six months to a year.
It like,
that'd be permanent.
What's the uh,
Rogan board member who posted this?
Uh,
Ajl Al Wolf.
Wolf in the house.
Look at that top one.
That's crazy.
That looks like somebody like,
well lit it on fire.
Yeah,
it looks like someone's cooking it over a fire exit is pretty bad.
As I'd be kind of cool that it would not feel good.
Meanwhile,
people are going to do that.
Yeah.
Well he used to be in this clarification then I found it really cool shoes
getting jellyfish.
Sea snakes are as dangerous as cobras.
Whoa.
What the fuck?
And those are the ones that are in Australia?
They're everywhere.
Well,
they think they originated from a land snake,
but they're in that western Pacific and the Indian Ocean warm waters.
So,
oh,
there's 16 types of CSNYC 57 species of sea steaks.
We had ETFs on the podcast and he was telling us how big Kangaroos cat and that
they can kill people.
Oh,
absolutely.
There's huge.
Don't beat the crap out of you.
Yeah.
I was like,
what?
Kangaroo Gut.
You don't like rip your guts out.
Fucking
how many deaths by kangaroo put in here?
Let's take a wild guess.
Uh,
I would say,
well,
they're only really in Australia,
right?
So I was going to say 17.
Hmm.
I'll go with 10.
Don't we count kids?
Yeah.
Humans.
How many people are killed by Kangaroos in Australia each year and the answer
is,
oh,
it was extremely rare.
It's very,
very rare.
Apart from road deaths caused by hitting swerving to miss kangaroos.
The only reliable documented case of a fatality from kangaroo attack occurred in
New South Wales in 1936 a hunter was killed when he tried to rescue two dogs
from a heated fray with a kangaroo.
Huh?
That's interesting.
There's a videos of them going psycho online,
a kangaroo getting angry at golf courses and stuff like people were also to be,
the government tries to cover it up.
I tried to cover up kangaroo desks.
He thinks I got this.
That's it.
What?
Its head cut off.
Yeah.
That's going to bite.
That's insane.
It's trying to get those people and its head is chopped off 24 hours.
Well,
I guess you could chop off its body and a lot of spots and it'll still stay
alive for a long time.
I don't know if it's true,
but also I get used to tell us they could grow back.
Primitive animal,
a snake,
and you see that thing,
they're supposed to be terrifying.
You know,
like there was a group that was working hard to conserve the Komodo Dragon.
They were talking about how important it is to conserve the largest fall Lippard
lizard species of like,
are you out of your fucking money?
Right?
One of those,
shoot it stuff.
It take videos of the rest and then nuke it from space.
Fly above in a jet and shoot rockets into those country lizards.
They're fucking terrifying.
They have botulism and their saliva.
You ever seen what a,
how a Komodo dragon kills?
No.
Oh,
Google Komodo dragon kills water buffalo.
They just run up,
bite them,
and then follow them for a few days until they just fall from the toxic saliva.
They fall to the ground and then they start eating them guts first.
Where do they live in China?
Komodo islands.
Oh Wow.
Something like that.
Komodo dragons where they live chemo and they're limited to one island.
Really?
They're not on land.
I thought they were like in a,
I mean,
they're in zoos,
right?
They,
um,
there's a thing called,
uh,
island dwarfism and it's one of the reasons why they were really concerned like
that,
that it works on everything,
but it doesn't work at everything.
It doesn't work on lizards.
Like elephants are smaller,
they have small elephants that are trapped on an island and people become
smaller and they're trapped on islands.
And a,
that's also one of the reasons why they believe in the island of Flores had
those little tiny hobbit people,
those little three foot tall people.
I think there's a thing called island dwarfism,
but with lizards it's the exact opposite.
When you put lizards on an island,
they get fucking big.
It's really weird.
Look at this thing.
Boom.
He just bites the leg and once he bites its leg,
okay.
I mean his,
the toxicity of this Conti Lizard Saliva.
Then he just follows him around for a few days until it's poor fuck.
Just start shaking like look at,
let me see him.
He's like barely getting by.
And then the Komodo dragon is just waiting right there to Jag.
Um,
okay.
Jack [inaudible] guts first.
Well,
it's just crazy that there's anything left with the word dragon in it.
Yeah.
I mean,
it's in a few Indonesian islands.
Komodo,
Rinca,
Flores,
Gil montage and [inaudible].
Those are the islands where this thing exists.
Those are the natural islands.
So it's basically live there amongst them.
Yeah.
Islands of Indonesia.
Some,
some of the islands know some of the items are unpopulated I believe.
Oh,
but some of them,
yeah.
I mean this thing is,
it's a scary fucking thing.
How do you kill it?
You shoot it.
It's normal.
Schiff bullets.
Fire rockets.
Hello.
There was a,
uh,
an incident where Sharon Stone was married to.
This guy was like a report or some shit like that,
and they went into a cage with commodity and didn't,
he got bit right then.
It's foot.
So his foot was a rabbit and white socks on.
So the,
the Komodo dragon thought his foot was a rabbit and his,
he got fucked by us.
I don't think he died,
but I think he was really badly hurt.
Got divorced.
Yeah.
Well,
Komodo Dragon.
Let's see.
Should I remember those braces?
Sharon Stone yesterday,
that magnetic bracelets.
And getting a lot of email.
They work.
Brian,
did you really?
You guys are super skeptical and I think that's bullshit.
Just skeptical but cynical and you use your bro Science.
That's hilarious.
Are you talking about the habits of magnets but the bear survival bracelet?
Oh those are actually common.
You buy those at like um,
his little whistle.
All the camp ground places,
rei places like that.
They've been selling those things forever.
Not with like a stupid whistle attached to it but I,
this is probably a good move to have.
Like what are the,
what's the reasoning?
If you cut one of those threads,
one of those,
you can unravel that thing and you have like several yards of really strong rope
that you can use for survival.
Like
you can carry your weight,
you can drag things with it.
You could make a pack,
you can bring bundle up some sticks and carry it and you could bring it back to
your camp.
Like you can use it for survival.
Anything to use it as a tourniquet.
Like when you would need a some rope,
you can use that stuff.
Oh,
I thought it was to help you protect it from bears.
Like what are you gonna get tired?
This little rope around the bears and the mouth while it's in your face.
No,
that wouldn't know unless you were just a gangster with a,
when she was just really bad ass with a rope.
So yeah.
So this thing,
um,
attack,
this dude is San Francisco Chronicle editor,
Phil Bronstein,
who is married to Sharon Stone,
who they were being treated to a private tour of the reptiles cage at the La Zoo
and he didn't have his shoes on.
I don't know why.
I guess like your shoes carry diseases or something.
They're worried about the fucking dragon,
this country monster with saliva of it.
Why would you want to get in the cage anyway to start with?
Let's take a private tour of the anamoly of the animal's home that's going to
kill you.
It would almost severed off his big toe.
The damage was exacerbated by the fact that Bronstein was barefoot at the time,
so it wasn't even white socks.
Oh.
He had removed his white tennis shoes before entering the cage.
After learning that the lizard was fed on a diet of white rats and might confuse
bronze teens feats for his next meal.
So this stupid bitch took his shoes off on a wall.
I don't want them affect,
my sneakers are a,
a rabbit trail foot.
The creature proved more myopic than officials anticipated.
Wow.
Stone who watched,
horrified from outside the cage,
later told San Francisco Chronicle that the lizard clampdown on Bronstein his
foot and became thrashing its body to and fro.
Fortunately,
Braunstein managed to free himself with the aid of it accompanies zookeeper who
was able to escape by clambering through the cages feeding hatch.
I would come back with an ax 100%.
It'd be like,
I don't know.
I don't care what you say.
I'm coming back with an ax.
I'm going to pay off the zookeeper guy and I'm going to come in there and I'm
going to hack that mother fucker to death and make a belt out of them.
Did the venom get it?
Oh yeah.
I mean,
I'm sure he had to be treated.
He,
uh,
he's in satisfactory condition at the time of this thing.
Um,
he apparently he's alive now,
but this was back in 2001.
Yeah.
I wonder if it's like the snake that I'm,
where you get paralyzed and you know,
it shuts your whole system down.
Like if you got bitten by a copperhead or something like that,
that's how it kills you.
Um,
no,
it's,
I think it's botulism.
I think that's what it is.
I think the,
um,
the poison inside is basically just like rotting evil shit onside.
This thing's mouth.
Just the bacteria that grows inside of its mouth and what's,
find out colonel dryly guns.
Yeah.
But the idea that people would go way out of their way to make sure these things
are still alive.
Right.
Well,
I mean,
there's a lot,
there's a lot.
I mean,
it's kind of interesting to see them and I do agree that there's an educational
aspect to having crocodiles and lizards and things that your kids can see.
My kids love going to the zoo and seeing the,
the weird fucking animals.
I can probably kill you locked up in a cage,
but,
but man,
I dunno.
Well damn infected with so much bacteria that the bites can be deadly in the
bacteria spread from dragon two dragon.
Aw,
yeah.
Boom.
Pray that escape one dragon often spread poison to the other dragons like one
dragon.
We'll get bite it and it'll get all this bacteria in it too.
That show run away and another dragon won't bite it.
And then that's how they get their bacteria and give it to each other.
Wow.
Rose.
Yeah.
Poor dental hygiene is what kills you.
You know?
The educational aspect of it is you don't need to see a real one to learn about
one.
Look how much we've learned today.
There's no dragon in here,
but we're learning.
You don't need a real one.
They're pretty dope.
I mean,
I,
I don't want them here,
but if they're on an island somewhere,
it's pretty dope.
But you can go and show up in a boat and videotape these crazy little dinosaurs
that are still alive.
Just a view as to at one point in time when dinosaurs really did own the earth.
If you go to these small islands,
these mother fuckers are running shit.
They're gigantic.
Huge evil lizards do.
They get their huge,
I think they get like more than way more than nine feet.
They're the biggest lizards.
They're not the biggest reptiles.
Crocodiles are the biggest reptiles,
but Komodo dragons are the biggest lizards.
I mean,
there are so nasty to,
Ooh,
well that one looked really bad.
I don't want to see it fit.
They grow to a 150 pounds and they can be three meters long.
10 it says 10 feet and weighing up to 150 pounds.
Yeah.
Right here it says the unusual large size has been attributed to island
gigantism since no other carnivorous animals filled a niche on the islands where
they live.
However,
the recent research suggests that the large size of Komodo dragons may be better
understood as a representative of the relic population of very large Vera Nid,
lizards that once lived across Indonesia and Australia,
most of which along with other mega fauna died out after the pleistocene.
So the pleistocene,
which was wow,
I'm looking at the pictures.
Don't do.
I looked at the face and one,
they're nasty.
Yeah.
Wow.
You're fucking evil.
There's a great picture of one with its mouth wide open and you see all its
country saliva,
see all that juicy poison roaming around and it's evil,
stinky mouth.
Some of them are green and then some of them are brown.
You know what's really interesting?
I bet someone's fucked one of those things take.
So yeah,
if there's an animal is a guy who was fucked it a local,
I don't think there's any for anything to,
they haven't fucked
someone somewhere along the line that's known about these things.
I mean if people have lived on the same planet as he's Kimono dragons for a
thousand years,
for sure.
One bad motherfucker had to have sex with one.
Yup.
And there's the one laying down that I think probably just shot a load right
into a Komodo Dragon.
And just to let everybody know I'm a job the second in charge of this island,
I'm dominating this island.
If you,
uh,
yeah,
if you have an animal that a guy can hold down someone's fuck that somebody is
going to do it and they agree.
Canaries,
I can't,
someone's fucking narrowed it down to a bird.
They fuck the fuck chickens to death all the time.
A lot of people have done that.
Super Common.
Maybe Asians,
not agents.
Why would you say Asians and every bird?
Oh,
cause it's smalls.
I he's joking that they're just cute.
I thought you meant the chicken.
I'm like,
no,
it's two valid.
Okay,
well here's another one from really
certainly the sister Commodos bite isn't an infectious at all.
For years,
Komodo dragons have been thought to be filthy.
Mouths have filthy mouth.
It was said to the rotting flesh from past meals with collecting the teeth and
gums which shouldn't turn accumulate deadly bacteria.
This hypothesis jelled with observations made by herpetologists Walter,
often Berg,
who in the 1970s and eighties found even when Komodo dragons failed to bring
down massive pray like water buffalo,
a Bitton buffalo would succumb to sepsis within a matter of days.
Thus,
research researchers believed,
suggested that the Komodo had not just a venomous bite,
but aseptic one.
But now newly published findings revealed at the Komodo dragons bite is rather
ordinary and in fact no more toxic than many in any other carnivore.
The findings were made by a team led by venom researcher Brian Fe.
That's interesting.
Well,
he showed that the bacteria present in the Kimonos mouths are surprisingly
ordinary,
similar to what scientists find in any carnivore.
And more importantly,
the oral flora doesn't possess the pathogenicity required to kill.
As for previous research found about violent bacteria,
the author notes that those species were identified without the advantage of
molecular methods of the 54 pre,
uh,
that previous research claim to be potentially pathogenic.
33 of actually common microbes and unlikely to be the cause of the rapid fatal
infection when president of mood.
Huh?
That's interesting.
So what the fuck is what?
How's it killing people?
I don't know.
It says you have to visit,
discover to find out.
Okay,
so it was a discover.
What the fuck?
Let me get to the end here.
Figure it out.
Tell me what's up.
Did,
did,
did it,
do they have venom?
Okay.
Monitor lizards.
A steak was venom is still mining reluctant.
Komodo Dragon Mri.
Is this Steve Arvin?
Crazy asshole.
Okay.
I was so nuts right away from it though.
Here's crawling around with them earlier in the video.
Cranky.
Well,
they're saying that some of them,
it's from the,
the bleeding.
The reason buffaloes get away from Kimonos aren't naturally equipped to take
down such large beasts.
Smelling his foot like,
oh God.
It's getting right up to him.
Yeah.
He just smelled his foot.
He's fucking crazy.
He lets those things get that close to him.
He did let those things get that call.
Some boy,
that guy dance with the devil for a long time before you got got.
Yup.
It's a fight.
A fight broke out right in front of him.
Great Point.
Two young miles.
[inaudible] they know that adults having a stand off midnight guy.
Very powerful animals.
He now I can.
Yeah,
so they do have venom.
Yeah.
Okay.
Don't worry.
You won't die of Sepsis from a Kimono bite.
You just die when the gigantic lizard with the inch long serrated teeth dripping
with hemorrhagic venom tears your flesh into shreds.
Oh,
it's hemorrhagic venom.
The strange interaction between a novel meal option.
No tourists.
Bees confused early investigators for water buffalo had never been introduced
onto the island.
Then this enhancing fairytale would have never come into existence.
Do,
do,
do this pitch around deep lacerations.
Oh,
is that his kid?
No,
I don't know who's getting this.
Okay,
so what they're saying is that it just the environment in which these animals
live,
anytime there's any sort of a deep laceration,
the environment is so filled with life and bacteria and jungle infect you.
Yeah.
You get infections or just what happens?
The buffalo wallow in stagnant warm water filled holes with their open feces.
The sewage fills hope filled holes say,
says fry our breeding pits of pathogenic bacteria when the water buffalo go
stand at the toxic water with gaping wounds that they get infected.
And it's really been that simple all along they're saying it's a previous
research.
Okay,
so now they know.
So it's not saliva,
it's not poisoned all.
It's just a bite.
And anything that goes in that water with a big open sore is just going to
fucking die in a couple of days.
I'm gonna make sense.
Yes.
So they're really good at killing pigs in deer.
That's their natural prey size.
So the water buffalo are large law a lot larger,
so that's why they,
they can't really take 'em out.
They just bite them and cut them open and then eventually,
so we learned something today.
Yeah,
we did.
Do you feel better about Komodo dragons?
No,
I don't either.
No.
I fucking hate those things.
I would like to be in,
like you said though,
in a boat that was not on shore.
Okay.
I like to be under this looking at it,
but yeah.
Yeah.
There's a lot of things out there that can fuck you up.
That's why we made cities.
Exactly.
Just get in your car,
going to keep it together.
Bitch.
Don't be bringing pythons and your fucking neighborhood and letting them loose
in your yard.
No,
Florida.
It's Florida.
Can you hear about the herpes infected monkeys in Florida?
I did.
Did you hear a thousand of them?
There's a thousand of growing breeding population of a thousand herpes infected
monkeys.
All of this living with old people who don't even know it's happening all the
way down.
All this capable.
There's are like a different kind of a herpes.
It's a herpes.
It kills people.
It's not like you get a bump on you and you got to go take some medication.
No,
this herpes like fucks your,
your neural system up.
Like you're,
you're done.
This is herpes be what?
Monkey herpes.
I,
I'm,
I'm not even,
I'm not even clear on why there's wild monkeys in Florida.
Apparently they were brought in as part of like a Tarzan show that they put on.
Seriously.
Yeah.
And then they,
you know,
just too fucking complicated.
People in Florida,
they get rid of their kids,
they send them to the jungle.
Everybody goes to everything.
Whenever you got,
just let it loose in the swamp.
But see what happens.
And these monkeys,
you started breeding and that was a thousand of them.
Thousand Rhesus monkeys with herps freezing.
Herps the kill.
I mean,
it's basically this,
the opening scene to 28 days later.
You know that,
that's Zombie movie where the monkey gets the range and then they run around
biting people.
Well,
the recent ones are so small too,
and they're fast.
They're quick as shit.
That's a problem.
And what are they eating?
They must be eating something.
Oh,
anything in the swamp?
Yeah,
there's enough to eat Kraft thousand of them.
Herpes infected monkeys.
Florida is so strange.
It's like another planet.
It really is.
It's amazing.
Now for Comedians,
it's like one of the greatest resources ever.
Mountain lions.
The panthers,
pythons keep going out over at Florida.
How about the people?
Forget about all the animals that drive.
If you go across the state,
what do they call alligator alley from Muss Palm to Tampa.
[inaudible] America's finest.
Yeah,
it's creepy spot.
Well,
it's so transient.
That's why in like so many criminals and then you get the people who go,
I don't want to pay no state tax,
and they all run in Florida.
So you've got that group.
You've got my parents and their friends and just kind of Washington state.
Seattle is no state tax either.
They don't know where to see
lance too far.
I don't even talk Canadian.
They don't even have bass tournament's.
They don't know.
Yeah,
they have a contest to kill pythons and you win money and they didn't kill any
at a bunch of people on the couldn't get any.
It wasn't enough money either.
It's like 1000 bucks.
Really?
That's not enough money to win you only 1000 bucks.
Yeah,
but you have to kill a python.
I think somebody won.
I saw pictures of one probably went to a pet store.
Fucking beat something to death with a hammer.
Maybe for a grant.
I would do that.
Yeah.
They probably can't sell them anymore.
Right?
Isn't that what happens?
They're killing.
No,
they killed him.
1500 bucks is what you get per python if you win.
I mean if they had 1500 bucks per python,
this is just bragging rights.
The 2013 python challenge.
We're kickoff this January.
Yeah.
Maybe they have another one this year.
Just this is just,
oh,
they,
okay.
They did turn in [inaudible] 68 of them.
Yeah.
There's more than a million acres of swamps and saw grass and they found 68 of
these fucking pythons.
Well,
they're hard to find.
I know,
but it's not amazing.
They found 60 60 that's what I'm saying.
I knew it was a lot.
To me.
That's a lot that if you're,
how many of them are out there?
Good Shit.
Heads.
I got a picture on here of this guy holding one.
Look how long it is.
Oh,
they're disgusting.
He's holding it by the tail.
Yeah,
it's enormous.
They found 1819 feeders footers.
They're feeders.
I don't think there are poisonous,
but they bite.
They'll fuck you up.
Yeah.
They grab a hold of union constrict you.
They've came,
they've killed kids.
They're really dangerous.
I know they're constrictors but they also bite.
I think people think,
oh,
it's a constrictor.
It won't bite.
Then still bytes.
Of course.
No Venom.
Right?
Yeah.
It doesn't have venom,
but it doesn't need it.
Right.
It's a gigantic crushing vice,
but just squeeze the life out of you and they also like time your breath.
Like they know when you breathe out.
That's when they clamped down.
So now he can't breathe and that's how they keep getting further.
Further constricts your case and why is it okay to have them in your home and
I'll probably get hate mail for that,
but fucking crazy.
That's why I think it's crazy.
That's the largest snake.
It was a 50 foot longs to 43 foot long size of a,
like a,
a bus.
Oh,
that's a titan boa.
Right.
That's what they call a titanic boa
anymore allegedly.
But they have anacondas that they think people have cited anacondas that are 90
feet long.
Shut up.
I have an anaconda wallet that used to be a
snake and I can go fuck itself.
Really?
Yeah.
Uh,
not really into snakes.
I am um,
the freakiest thing of all snake things to me.
Is it a King Cobra can't stand up half its body length.
Yeah.
So if we were in a Indian rice field,
a Cobra could come up and cobras can grow up to be like 18 feet.
It could be nine feet tall.
You could come upon and he's only half up.
I mean,
how,
seriously,
how could anyone eat
cobras are so dope.
Look into what a crazy body,
that whole fan thing that it does.
Wow.
Giant Anaconda and Wiki PD.
Oh my God.
150 feet.
What?
Listen to this.
Reports of giant Anaconda is date back as far as the discovery of South America,
when sightings of Anacondas,
upwards of 50 meters began to circulate amongst colonists and the topic has been
the subject of debate ever since.
Among crypto zoologist in zoologists,
anacondas can grow to 20 feet and beyond and 330 pounds plus in weight.
Although some python species can grow larger and Anaconda,
particularly in green or common anacondas the heaviest,
blah,
blah.
The largest,
longest reputably measured and confirmed Anaconda are 25 feet long and length
between 50 and 60 feet have been reported for this specimen,
but such extremes lacked verification.
The only reliable claims it can be found describe measured anacondas ranging to
39 feet.
Fucking a man,
150 fucking feet.
If that's true,
that's like means literally that.
That's like the size of a car.
How wide is that God damn thing if it's 140 50 feet long as this table fucking
a,
that was that awesomely bad movie with Jon Voight and Jennifer Lopez.
Every,
every seen Jennifer Lopez had a tire shoes.
She just had a bent over and stick her ass up in the air and they're just stuck
counts giant.
She uhg how size snakes dropping down and fucking up Utah.
And John Voight has the worst Brazilian accent of all time.
John Voight's a great actor,
but boy does he suck at playing in Brazilian.
He's really good.
And um,
what you call it?
Uh,
uh,
Ray Donovan.
Oh,
is he really?
Yeah,
he's great.
He watched that.
And showtime.
Showtime finish showtime person.
Yes.
Dexter homeland.
Ray Donovan.
Yeah.
He plays an old [inaudible] gentleman's good,
please.
Oh,
you'd love it.
Really?
Yeah.
I'd love fucking homeland.
Is it good as homeland?
Better shut your fucking mouth.
Not,
not,
not as a,
it's not as intense.
Oh,
what does it mean?
What's it better?
Because it has flowers.
Is that no,
it's better because it's fucked up.
Irish violence.
There's no terrorism and stuff.
This is just one guy out here.
You're gonna wish you had him in your life.
I've already thought of a hundred times.
Wish I had right Donovan.
I could call right now.
He solves your problems.
Really?
Yeah.
And wish you had someone like that in your life.
Do you remember that guy who got arrested who was like a famous detective out
here who was actually that kind of a guy?
All the,
uh,
the Hollywood elite would use this guy and you would let stalk people.
That's probably what they modeled this after beat people up.
Yeah.
He beats people up a lot.
Um,
those guys exist,
but you just gotta be in the music business.
In the comedy business.
We don't have access to those guys were too loose lipped.
We would have like,
I got a fixer.
We look,
write jokes about it.
You know,
I have a stalker.
I can't too many beers at the bar and told everybody about the guy told
everybody about my fixer.
The Guy,
you're not supposed to tell anybody it.
You're not supposed to tell what that guy does.
Eddie the bar tender.
I don't know.
Maybe he told other people Kathleen Madigan.
You're fucking hilarious comedian.
Thank you.
When is your raw special coming out?
It's out.
It's on Netflix right now.
Sally for 90 days.
Yeah.
[inaudible] then was released it onto the public.
I did it.
Knock it out.
Madigan again.
Yeah,
Matt,
again,
two words again.
I'm tired of thinking to titles.
That's a good way.
Tired that way.
People,
you know what it is.
It's against.
Yeah.
Again,
and it's on Netflix right now.
Yeah.
So it was bill burrs.
Um,
a lot of people put,
I have one from 2005 on there.
There's a lot of people have specials on Netflix now and so they're all the
rage.
All the rage,
all the kids are doing it.
Thanks for doing this.
We do it again.
Yeah,
we'll do it again sometime.
Yeah.
Awesome.
Beautiful.
All right.
And a file.
Kathleen on,
um,
Twitter on Twitter and Kathleen Madigan.
I love on Twitter.
You can get it.
I tweeted it today.
So if you can't spell Kathleen or Madigan,
see it's not hard.
K a.
It's not Madigan with an h,
one of those fucking fruity Madigan's.
No,
it's ultimately that,
again,
the age is fairly silent.
Um,
uh,
so follow her please.
On Twitter and,
uh,
may the force be with you.
Yes and no dragons.
And uh,
thanks to stamps.com for sponsoring this podcast.
Uh,
go to stamps.com.
Use The code word J,
r,
e.
N,
then go fuck yourself.
No,
don't do that.
Just use the code word and save some money.
And,
uh,
also,
um,
on at.com,
use the code word Rogan and save 10% off any and all supplements.
We're going to say Brown,
uh,
stand up live next Thursday.
Me and Tony Hinchcliffe are going to be there.
Uh,
please go to [inaudible] dot com it's going to be a good show.
There you go.
That's a good way to say it.
Yeah,
don't something nutty.
It's going to be a good show.
Go see the good show.
Uh,
next weekend I'll be at the comedy Magic Club on the 27th and the 28th.
And then the following week I will be,
uh,
at the Ontario Improv with Tom Segura for two days and then Tony Hinchcliffe on
Sunday.
So,
uh,
and we'll see you guys.
It's me,
Thompson,
Gore,
and Brian Callen.
Tomorrow,
people of Toronto find people of Toronto or the Sony Center,
and then we're probably going to do some other shit around town too.
And then there's the UFC this weekend.
Powerful dream life.
All right.
We'll see you freaks a soon.
Thank you everybody.
Thanks for all the love and,
uh,
and much happiness to everybody out there.
See you soon.
Bye.
Yeah.